welcome back to chess.com i'm not gm speechless
championship grand master robert hess alongside
me today grand master of mont hamilton amman
you've had quite a busy schedule lately how
you feeling today what's up robert and uh hello
to twitch chad good to be back good to be back
i have been commentating a lot but you know i i'd
like to think that this is just you know twitch
rivals maybe it was just practice for this i am
not a gm tournament robert yeah i like to say no
rest for the fantastic commentators you are great
so no rest for you and let's remind everybody
of what we're here for today because it's
been a while this is the i'm not a gm speed
chess championship the format is the following
as you see in front of you we have a bracket
single elimination knockout 75 minutes of five
minute plus one second increment blitz followed
by 45 minutes of the three plus one and finally
25 minutes of everyone's favorite ebola chess
only the winner survives and advances we will have
the one of the two finalists after today's match
and the prize money among it's getting bigger
and the participants should be quite happy to
take home 450 by themselves plus the 450 split
by win percentage and of course the chance at
the championship yeah that's that's awesome i you
know we were both a part of yesterday the twitch
rivals event where we saw uh so many people taking
home cash for their participation and i'd like
to see those rewarding formats where players are
taking home cash regardless of uh where they place
absolutely and we're going to remind everybody
of what we're here for today it is international
master molina an international master at lars
oscar hogg and as you see in the bracket there
are only four people remaining we are on the right
side of the screen here roberto lars on the left
side we have greg shahadi taking on levy rosman
and i guess before we dive into today's match
amman what do you make of the other one between
greg and levy i'm sure so many people are excited
for greg shahadi and gotham chess yeah i mean at
this point um the i am not a gm tournament has
progressed to the semi-final stage so we are so
close to crowning that uh winner and greg shahadi
uh speaking of potential winners number one seed
going into the entire event he's obviously a
front-runner um i think there is a lot of fans
of both sides here but you have the number one
seed in greg shahadi and then you have you know
fan favorite levy rosman who i think you'll maybe
echo this but every match we've commented of his
so far has been extremely exciting so i can't
wait for this this is going to be really really
tough to call i think greg has to be the favorite
going in but i think what we've seen from levy
is that he can win any match especially in the
bullet segment that's right he's been gaining
rating recently he's been posting about that
crossing 2100 to 2800 blitz of course and so he
is in good form but that's enough of that matchup
let's talk about today we have roberto we have
lars oscar hogg they are about to begin and i'm
not sure who the favorite is i know that lars has
been dominant in the bullet portion he has really
just been cruising by his opponents there but he
struggled out of the gates in the blitz portion
his openings have left him in a bit of trouble so
whose style do you think will be better between
these two players well i think that uh and what
we do know about these players as the first game
is uh underway here what we do know about these
players is uh i think we're gonna see a big style
mismatch which is why i'm so excited for the match
today because uh roberto very very solid you know
uh if you if you give the guy a trade he'll take
five of them so uh he'll be looking to go for
those end games but more positional style and
we've seen a very loose play from lars which is
why i think uh he's been doing so well in bullet
i think you're rewarded for being a little bit
more loose in your style when it comes to bullet
chests where you can't calculate everything else
so efficiently but in the blitz portion look for
roberto to try to press the advantages i would say
because i think that they're gonna see a few
openings that don't necessarily go um in the way
of lars oscar i agree with that and we already
see that roberto takes the calmer approach on
move five he went e3 rather than playing the more
adventurous tactical sequences with e4 so roberto
calmly enters this position here where white
has a bit more space thanks to that pawn on d4
but black has no weaknesses that can be targeted
so i would say that these styles of position are
more up roberto's alley hence his opening choice
in game one yeah and that uh column approach with
e3 is gonna mean uh you know you're not gonna see
these types of positions where uh i guess we might
see c5 it could immediately get very symmetrical
after something like c5 d capture c5 and
we get a position like that and uh just looking at
the position already i know that lars has got to
be happy with his opening because um it's actually
one of the one of the more solid approaches we've
seen from him at the same time it seems like it's
the exactly what roberto wants starting off here
that's true and i think now if he's gonna start
getting active i move like knight e5 comes to
mind you typically want to place a knight in the
square try to replace it with a pawn but i do like
bishop e1 first because you want the opening of
the d-file not just a pawn on e5 so i like bishop
e1 it's very calm it challenges lars to figure
out do i take on d4 no keeping the tension with d8
and d5 is an additional possibility for
white i'm just not sure how that plays out
agree yeah d5 is the first thing that i think of
here with bishop takes c3 being met by potentially
just d6 and in the meantime after d5 if you
exchange everything on that square sometimes those
end games they might look like nothing robert
but uh those equal end game positions with that
slight imbalance of pawns four versus three for
white on the king side three versus two for black
on the queen side those can sometimes materialize
into serious advantages at this high level
yeah you can be lulled into a sense
of comfort oh it's a fine position
nothing major happening but those end games as
you're saying they can be quite difficult to
hold and right now look at lars he's trying to
figure out what to do he is down 40 seconds on the
clock and still not making a move yet because he's
trying to figure out do i take on d4 do i play
h6 just to make luft for my king what move would
you play here mom well um yeah obviously i play
c takes d4 robert um but yeah see cd4 is always on
the cards for black that that pawn tension there
i was wondering mostly how roberta was going
to recapture if i i had to make a prediction
i would have actually said that he would
take back with a piece rather than a pawn
just stylistically but he's taken back with the
pawn he's looking at these d5 options still and
he does have that 95 move that you mentioned
so long ago so i think this game is sort of
revolving around the fact that the knight on f6
cannot jump into d5 so easily um because white can
immediately white can win a piece but um or not
quite win a piece but uh at least force that e
pawn to capture back and that knight on d7 can't
really get to b6 to d5 which is a really common
maneuver so i think the issue in this game is
might be surprising but the knight on d7 robert
doesn't have a lot of places to go and after
95 white's going to be tempting him to trade
that's true and the 997 dominated by pawn three
squares away that d4 pawn taking away four jumps
and also i would say that pawn on a6 a big problem
for black notice how lars went rook f to d and
then rook d to e8 and he still can't move his
rook on a8 because it's attached to that pawn
on a6 where the queen and bishop are lined up
on that side of the board so this is a tricky
position for lars to deal with and look at the
clock i mean so much more time for white here
bishop f4 is the move that i played there he goes
that bishop went from e1 doing not so much to f4
where maybe it's not threatening anything just yet
but it's a strong piece and now we're going to see
trade you said give him one he'll take five i
think uh let's uh let's get trades for three
yeah i'll get a get a full uh full-size offering
of trades with bishop h2 well i'm almost proud i'm
almost proud watching here robert well he said if
we're gonna trade it's gonna be a my turn to take
on c3 help my pawn out but that knight on d7 ahmad
you mentioned it it gets out but in comes knight
to e5 i do feel like we're still in roberto's
wheelhouse but it's getting a bit sharper now
that the knight on d7 has ventured over to f6 yeah
i definitely think that um taking on d5 was a sort
of a one-time opportunity a limited time offer
because the pawn would have to recapture and after
knight uh to f6 all of a sudden the pieces can
handle the recapturing rook a to c8 robert goes
back to what you were mentioning about the a6 bond
i mean why is uh is that pawn safe here can he get
away with rook a to c8 i don't think so knight
takes d5 followed by bishop takes a6 is what i'm
going for without much of hesitation uh there it
goes step one complete and no matter how you take
on d5 the a6 pawn goes down so it's one of these
positions amman where you start feeling all right
i'm doing better as black my first knight gets
to d5 my superfluous knight gets to f6 and now
one trade down goes a6 and you're just down a
pump perhaps there's some kind of queen g5 at some
timely moment hitting g2 hitting c1 i'm not quite
sure it works out but i would be looking for that
kind of tactical sequence yeah a hundred percent
if if bishop takes a6 i'm already wondering about
rook takes c1 followed by queen g5 as an idea
hitting the rook on c1 and eyeballing that g2
square um the bishop is still going to be on b7
so there's still some firepower lined up there and
it's also going to be stuff like you know knight
f4 knight c3 discovered attacks um if white's
not careful so that's what uh roberto is thinking
about here and and we mentioned the style clash at
the beginning of this matchup i think that those
types of positions are where lars really really
thrives where it gets messy and tactical and
he does have that sharp tactical vision and you
know that's for sure the case based on the time
situation where now we're about even on the clock
bishop takes a6 was played roberto puts on his
calculation cap and decides to go for it but queen
g5 right now is played by lars he doesn't need to
be asked twice where does this rook go to amman
yeah where does the rook go to is a great
question because um knight f4 sort of
looks like a i guess there's maybe queen g4 or
something in in the position like that but uh
it it looks really suspicious here i i don't
really know where this was like if you go rook to
d1 or basically a rook to any normal square i get
the feeling that black should be fairly happy with
uh some of the tricks in the position maybe even
just bishop to a8 um next move robert just keep
that guy and say all right uh i'm gonna threaten
some stuff next turn it's up to you i think you
have to avoid the knights jump because we keep
looking at knight f4 and that's where my mind was
i was tunneling but after rook d1 maybe there's
knight c3 because now we hit the queen and the
rook in the event of queen g4 so maybe you have to
play move like rook a1 just hide your rook all the
way away just to avoid some kind of knight jump
that would hit that rook in addition to the g2
square with checkmate that's crazy rook a1 being
required here is that's a tough uh pill to swallow
yeah because other moves like rook he goes rook c2
maybe that's also sufficient i thought there would
be a knight jump because but then i can't take
the own bishop on b4 but you need to stay out of
the bishop's path out of the knights path all of
these pieces for black doing well but your ideas
is coming to fruition here after knight f4 which
looks like a mating idea queen comes to g4 to stop
the checkmate and yes that bishop a6 will lose
the defender but then knight and f4 will lose its
defender as well so we're actually seeing a very
weird series of trades and the tactics are flying
yeah and i think that position after
knight f4 queen g4 is gonna liquidate
favorably for um for roberto and he's going to
be on the open file as well which is important
if that rook was on a1 like you mentioned
maybe that black can go for that line and
just go rook c8 at the end and start invading
so it is something to pay attention to that
keeping the queens on the board here is something
you want to do is is bishop a8 uh crazy because
with 48 seconds to 50 seconds if my knight f4
stuff is not working here i'm not too sure what
to do i might just play bishop a8 instinctively
it's one of these positions where i feel like you
have to trust your intuition and play metaphor but
he's thinking too long at this point because uh
bishop a8 then queen g4 anyway and it feels like
the queens are coming off or you're backtracking
and you no longer have an attack but lars now
is down on the clock roberto probably feeling
much happier about the state of his position and
94 eventually was played but what's the follow-up
yeah you can take this bishop right away or
you can decide to trade the queens rook c2
is actually really nice instead of rook a1
it prevents like queen d2 in a lot of lines
so it means the queens definitely get traded off
bishop takes f4 and these are the trades that
we're seeing but this is why i was uh pointing
out robert it's so good that the rook is on c2
on the open file and knight c6 isn't that just
a big fork yeah that's game over that's forking
the rook and the bishop there's not no way you can
protect the bishops you're going down a full piece
after movement resignation spot wow did you
see roberto there yeah he feels so relieved
after a stressful game one and lars is like i
mean he's he's shell-shocked from the blender but
he doesn't look that faced all right
that's that's game one for you you know
just getting started here just getting warmed up
that's the key just getting started and because
roberto is more of a kind of a traitor a player
who wants to say let's get pieces off the board
not have it be so complicated he has to bring
his gut with him today he's not just going to
be in here all right easy games look at this
what is this position on move seven right we
have pawns going up the board there's already
some kind of f takes e5 queen h4 check available
is that good i'm not positive but nor is roberto
and i'm sure lars isn't either but we're getting
crazy positions from the very start of the games
yeah this is uh this is trademark lars you know
the position is going to get um pretty spicy after
a move like this because immediately i think you
know everyone's eyes should be drawn to the idea
of hey pawn takes pawn on e5 and no matter how
that is recaptured black is already thinking
about the move queen h4 check just an immediate
uh you know attack when you see the move g4 and
f4 i mean we all know fools checkmate mr hess
and i mean those two moves invite a check like
that i mean what are we seeing here i think that
we're going to see maybe a g5 at some point and
we're going to lock that side of the board up but
that bishop on g6 not looking that great although
the g5 perhaps it goes to h5 just to try to keep
that side close i don't think that black can get
away with this i really believe that g5 knight g3
h4 just start throwing our pieces up the king side
and i'm not liking roberto's position that much
yeah after after f5 like g5 h4 with knight
g3 coming looks uh looks like a lot of fun
i think there's probably i was about to say
a knight g3 like a more aggressive way to
do the same thing where uh you want maybe pawn
takes pawn and then you could take back with
the queen you're coming with h4 h5 bishop
d3 um this is going to be a fight for some
of the light squares on the king side it's
really all about this f5 square if black
can you know continuously take back with a piece
and establish a piece on that square he's got a
really solid position meanwhile bishop d3 lars is
not looking to to let that happen i think you take
on g4 though and if you take on g6 maybe black
plays h takes g6 and gets a strong hold of this
f5 square with the pawns it doesn't look pretty
i acknowledge that but you can't allow yourself
in there we see the start of it you can't allow
yourself to just be pushed back move after move
and h takes g6 is a must here we go and i think
king f7 your king is surprisingly safe there
because of the pawn on d5 right knight can't get
over to g5 but for now i mean it makes sense let's
try to castle queen side that's probably smarter
not my games i'll put my king out of seven and
don't deal with the consequences but here he just
brings his king to the queen side and how does
white make progress despite the pleasant looking
position well i um immediately think of something
like i mean h4 just kind of locks everything down
if you really want to open things up and meanwhile
undermine the f5 square robert i think of h4 h5
to get rid of the g pawn in that case there's also
you know if you're ever not sure what to do in a
position like this how about the move king v1 and
king v8 those moves are your friends robert when
you queenside castle and you don't know what to
do next i think most people especially stronger
players will agree that hey if you play king b1
or king b8 you're not doing something wrong um was
he there partner and i think strategically white
is in a better position because this knight on
a6 is going to have to resort to passive defense
going to c7 in the near future but then again the
knight nc7 is very helpful because the pawn e6
is a target but i like this move h5 you're trying
to remove the defense of this f5 knight and queen
f7 i think is a nice response because after h6
g6 rook takes g6 at least for the time being
white isn't just quick enough to take on f5 so i
like how both players are playing this and i could
see this turning in roberto's favor i didn't like
his position to start with now all of a sudden
it seems like he's stabilized and that rook h6
move in particular felt clever yeah the the one
i guess fairly concrete line i'm looking at
is takes on g6 a rook g6 followed by queen h5
um and if somehow i can play knight takes f5
successfully and force upon the recapture not
sure about the end game i feel like white should
be slightly preferred last night will eventually
reach the e6 square so it's barely double-edged
i i would say i don't don't think either side is
uh got anything to write home about just yet
that's the annoying thing right your whole goal is
to undermine the defense f5 and then when you do
it a knight appears on e6 and you're like darn it
knights are the best blockading pieces but i think
you have to take on g6 at some point you're sort
of running out of time you don't want to allow
black to double in the h file and start causing
some problems so here we do see that trade and
queen h5 now that seems completely reasonable
but said he backs it up to f3 yeah queen queen h5
looked uh looked very normal i mean queen f3 is
absolutely nothing wrong with that move but um
queen h5 seemed to make sense to me i guess it
would be met by rook f8 all the same yeah
there's no way to pile up on the pinned
rook that would have been there so the queen
would have been defended anyway so now there's
this crazy amount of tension along the f5 the f5
square and the f4 pawn behind it if white takes an
f5 then in comes black's queen to f5 where look at
that c2 pawn by the way i'm on a timely knight b4
could spell some serious trouble for white that's
a great point that's a great point we might see
an immediate rook h5 after queen takes f5 in order
to dissuade exactly what you're talking about you
don't have time to get knight before in you've got
to move your queen back to f7 and then temporarily
white is the one who sort of has control over
that f5 square we might see rook h5 f5 knight
f4 just some quick activation ideas that would be
a thematic pawn sack but if the rook h5 can play
rook g5 and offer you a trade wow that's just cute
i think you have to because i don't want to be
pushed back queen f70 f5 looks like a great pawn
sack he goes queen g4 all right not giving white
the opportunity to press forward just yet but i
thought rookie five was a way to trade some pieces
and keep some of the pressure on white's position
he was neither as passive as i was suggesting or
as flashy as you were suggesting just queen
g4 nice and simple uh get those trades in
and white's better here because that knight
on e2 covers f4 whereas the g7 pawn the e6
pawn those are both weaknesses rook h7 being the
obvious next move for white just putting pressure
on the pawn and i think that black it's about
time maybe knight c7 your knight going up to
b4 does all of nothing it'll get kicked right
back to a6 so knight c7 at least protects e6
one of your two potential vulnerabilities yeah the
other move i would consider is just king over um
king d7 seems ever more natural than king d8 but
same idea that you may want to bring that king to
f7 at some point and uh one thing to watch out
for even though it's tempting is let's say this
king gets to f7 and white starts thinking about f5
sometimes takes takes and you know the black king
goes to e6 or if the rooks get traded black is the
one that's going to have the outside pass pawn so
although white is going to get a protected pass
bond in the middle we've talked already about how
it can be blockaded uh successfully and i i know
he's got f5 available but i'm just not sure that
that's necessarily the right right way to proceed
robert yeah that's a good point because we've been
talking to f5 for so long that you made just that
you have to play it when given the opportunity
and now i'm blacking by king g6 and say you're
not getting your f5 movement uh-huh everyone's
bringing the king towards the middle finally
that knight does retreat uh to c7 looking to
get involved somehow and it now i think the move
f5 is less and less likely because the knight is
ready to jump into e6 and you give black the
outermost past pawn when you play f5 because
right now the g7 pawn is met by the f4 pawn but
as soon as you play f5 and get some trades then
the g pawn actually becomes a passer so i'm with
you i think that f5 is less and less likely but
i don't know how to proceed otherwise me i would
say b3 and c4 but i'm like then what the d5 square
is so well defended i don't actually know how to
break through here yeah i think this is the type
of position where you just kind of play c3 you
kind of play a4 a few uh a few moves for white
that seem natural i also wouldn't be surprised by
maybe the king even rerouting further towards the
king side and uh basically the position is exactly
what it says it is uh dead level and i think that
lars is the one who actually has to accept the
draw here because if he gives up control of the
h file he could be in trouble so after king g7 the
next move will be rook h8 but rook h8 here will be
met by f5 because the rook on g1 pins the pawn on
g6 to the king that's why roberto shifts his king
right back to f7 perhaps he could you know move
his work i would not even think about it at this
point no reason to get tactical you're holding
steady with the black pieces and the draws agreed
yeah and that's a sort of a just feeling out
just feeling out the uh the competition here
draw early on both players get on the scoreboard
you know you're you're probably happy as lars just
to get that half point up there and go to the next
game that's not the type of position that we've
seen lars score his points from in this tournament
so far right and now we get to game three once
again the white pieces for roberto he plays a
very solid position right he just pushes pawns
in the center developed castled kingside gave his
opponent an isolated queen pond but perhaps this
is a position that suits both of them because
strategically from a structural point of view
white is happy to give black an isolated pawn but
lars is saying wait a second maybe i'll get a an
attack on the h2 pawn you don't have a knight on
f3 so if i can line my pieces up against your king
side there are some attacking prospects i think
both players should be happy out of the opening
yep i agree um this looks like uh just right
off the bat it sort of feels like one of those
isolated pawn positions where black should
be a bit happier than than usual um i always
find that bishop on f3 to be a little bit awkward
moves like knight e5 putting pressure immediately
on that bishop and knight takes e6 is sort of like
a fake threat like i never really am convinced by
knight takes e6 because black takes with the
f pawn and opens up the rook and immediately
is threading like moves like e5 e4 so i'm not too
sure if uh roberto should be that happy with his
position he's already gotten rid of the isolated
pawn by capturing on c6 yeah something has gone
wrong i don't like the decision to take on c6 but
as you point out knight e5 was probably a concern
of his and that's why he took there but now that
pawn on d5 is very well defended and okay i'm
taking with the f pawn but perhaps queen takes is
the right choice here but i would take with the f
pawn and not even think about it because then you
have a mobile pawn center and here comes e5 you
mentioned that move then perhaps e4 and what are
these bishops doing for white it feels like you're
several moves behind in terms of development
mm-hmm yep no definitely a more of a lars move to
play f takes e6 like he's very interested in the
imbalances um and it's not even for that reason
that you might play it because look at that center
i mean how how do you say no to that there's no c
pawn that's going to be undermining uh the center
here can't even push e the e pawn that easily like
e4 definitely a move i would consider but tough to
play if white can get e4 and black plays d4 those
are the type of light square imbalances that i
think roberto would be looking to create but after
b4 he's hinting at you know queen b3 b5 trying to
undermine this way i think it could be a little
bit slow here robert yeah you desperately try to
seize control the light squares for your bishop
but i like black's position we both do and one
of the ideas that i do like about this b4 move is
black could have considered pawn e4 and bishop to
e5 when your opponent has a bishop pair and you
can trade off one of them and then have a knight
against a bishop you can dominate the other color
complex however b4 does have this continued threat
of undermining the pawns on d5 that pawn needs to
be defended by that pawn on c6 for the most part
the a7 pawn stuck in place potentially a target
with queen a4 at some moment so i'm not sure
anymore i'm sort of second guessing myself i
like black's position and all of a sudden saying
this doesn't look so easy to make progress despite
this great pawn center and this bishop on d6
yeah that's a that's a good point the the move e4
opens up the bishop towards the king but without
the access to the g4 square for black's knight
it's very hard to coordinate on that square like
you know you don't have uh bishop b8 queen d6
so easily and if you do white will happily just
play g3 and uh and kill that idea so uh i agree
it sort of feels like one of those positions
that lars is maybe getting the same feeling
that you and i are right now if you look at the
clock i mean he's down more than a in a minute
getting close to a minute and a half that uh
he's thinking here because he's trying to find
the right plan and speaking of the right plan
i don't think that c5 is the right plan but
it's what he's chosen because he had to make
a move just couldn't find what he should do so
he went for this and it's not bad i don't
think either of us believe that but after
this trade on d6 coming our way or maybe
i guess you have to trade d6 now because
it works in c4 and then just moves like queen b3
omega 3 is bad because rook b8 but well it knows
bishop takes d5 check that's actually a really
cool tactic i blundered it there you go robert
oh my gosh well there are tactics everywhere
it seems but that's been sweet yeah i i it
was a mistake that it happened but i'm just going
through some of these positions and yeah you know
what robert you've convinced me i you deserve a
spot on the analysis board thank you thank you
you know rookbee it looks like it just kicks
the queen away but the queen on d6 can't take
on d5 and protect the rook on v8 so beautiful oh
gosh so what what's this position though i'm on
because it does feel like black is way more active
here and yet i see the eval bar on screen saying
completely equal yeah i mean well unfortunately
your bishop d5 isn't working in every position so
we can't lean on that here queen b4 looking for a
queen trade and queen d3 uh there's e4 to consider
so lots and lots of reasons why you know you'd
be tempted by the trade i think that allowing
the trade on b3 is sort of comfortable because
you take with the b pawn and you can swing your
rook over to a file so even something simple and
calm on the on the king side like g3 or h3 just
that a little escape square so your rook can go to
the a file afterwards and do something aggressive
like rick takes a7 i think that would be the best
way forward and roberto he knows how to play these
end games and it just seems like some pawns will
get traded off and neither side will have enough
remaining and the pawns will be on the same side
of the board sure black has two central pawns and
then two king side pawns and white only has one
pawn island but the knight is very good on f6
defending his d5 pawn so there's nothing to worry
about from black's perspective and from white's
perspective it's like you can't attack anything
once the queen's come off so it seems like it
should just be an equal game yeah and i like
the move queen before uh by lars it might not be
you know the move that gets the brilliancy award
or anything like that but i think that if you
stayed in the position with queens uh on the board
it was going to benefit roberto the the longer the
game went on a simple move like rook d1 coming
up next would put a lot of pressure on the d-pawn
with the queen on d6 you'd be threatening queen
takes c4 so i just like the idea to trade off um
even though it might not be uh you know the most
aggressive move or the most aggressive way to play
but those are very important moments in chess
that are taken for granted it's like well you
all he did was offer a queen trade it's like
well if he didn't do that he probably would
have suffered in the position it would have become
increasingly difficult to fend off some of white's
plans and thus could have caused a losing game
so i actually think that this is a moment that
we should give credit to lars for recognizing the
potential danger and by roberto's time management
right now he is really in the think tank and about
to be at one minute and now lars might be thinking
wait a second i thrive in bullet maybe i can
play for more despite the board situation being
one that should be equal and you know you might
say wow queen you know before not so impressive
well it caused roberto to think for like two
and a half minutes there robert so i mean that's
that's just a testament or proof right there from
roberto himself that that was a very strong move
and he was probably trying to figure out a way to
avoid getting a super passive position you don't
want to sit and have a defensive rook against
your opponents attacking rook and that's why
he was just trying to see do i play g3 should i
play rook b1 first what's the right move order and
g3 was his choice now lars has a bit extra time
let's get look at this move king f7 we're getting
into an end game let's bring that king to e6
i actually think that white's position is more
difficult to play right now yeah i i'm pretty
close to just saying like queen d1 um keep the
queens on the board and try to play against that
last move king f7 say like oh you know you're
trying to cut the line basically um trying to get
to the end game one move ahead of the end game
itself and queen d1 just keeping the queens on
the board maybe makes the king look a little silly
i like that idea and for lars now he has to weigh
that well the d5 pawns on attack can you really
play king e6 here after king e6 white actually
can't keep the queens on because queen d3 is met
by e4 oh actually is there a bishop g4 check there
wait a second wait if i can keep the queens out
i'm keeping the queens on exactly exactly there
is bishop g4 check i think but even if there is
and that's not established yet um a black could
just move the king back it's not so clear that's
true you can just move the king away and say
maybe you've committed too much to keep the
queens in the pick go back to g8 and say
okay well now you kept the queens on gotcha
what's that called you know castling by hand is
a thing what's that called when you run your king
in the center and then run it back i don't know we
got to come up with that almost it's almost like a
like a suicide at a track meet or something
like that is it yes who's that sprint there
yeah it's yeah it's uh tough to give a true name
to but 12 seconds left for roberto this honestly
is lars's time i would even consider a5 right
now just trying to be as advanced as possible
in the position and maybe there's king d6 in the
near future trying to bring the king into c5 it
seems like a joke but if i can get my king over
to the square c5 i'm ready for this end game 100
100 and even as we start to get into a potential
end game like uh trading the queens the king is
also just closer to running to the the queenside
pawns so even trading queens becomes a serious
option and rooksy too well now that bishop needs
to stay put because knight g4 would be devastating
three moves how can black rook a2 i think that's
probably the best way to keep that pawn on a7 safe
now rook a1 okay once these pawns come off i don't
think there's any danger for white yeah i'm trying
to think about how things could go wrong a black
sort of has the draw if he wants it with rook b1
rook b2 because i don't think that the bishop
can move as you pointed out but uh you know he
obviously wants more than that it's five seconds
for his opponent as you said this is where lars is
going to play this game on maybe there's some kind
of rook b1 rook e1 and try to create a meeting
if that knight can find its way to f3 that's a
very far way away but i know that if my knight
gets to f3 and my rook gets to b1 i could try to
checkmate the white king in there so okay wait
rookie one coming yeah i don't know if i'm there's
rook c2 after rookie one i don't know if i'm a big
fan of g4 not at all as a move because even if
the rooks trade now there's there's something
to play for wow f3 what a move to play with four
seconds in your clock but if you take knight takes
e4 this is looking scary knight g3 check is a fork
the king comes in even as well yeah there's a lot
of good ways to take it we have two broke up two
one piece oh my goodness you wanted this rookie to
check king c rook f2 oh no d5 is hanging
oh gosh yeah the d5 pawns hanging now it's
a draw again oh my goodness yeah even though
this is not beautiful for roberto this is uh
um this is gonna be a draw yeah this is sufficient
here although you know if you take on g4
and white takes at the wrong point there could be
a losing king upon you but here you take and then
create opposition you need to be able to create
opposition not be in it to begin with oh don't
take on g4 yeah do not take on g4 one second he
barely got that move off what oh my goodness and
it is a draw knight he's gonna play nine of five
then he'll take on a five if he ever does that so
so if he can he's looking for king f1 king like
h2 and at the right moment you sneak that pawn by
what would that [ __ ] want to eat no way
yeah so i would have kept the king on g3
and waited for this shuffling that white's
doing with the king um because then it could
work yeah knight f3 just take it and king f1
he's going away
that's funny
oh no that was a fun one look at
roberto he's stressed man he he just
he just breathed out a heavy sigh of relief again
so these games are getting to him and you want to
know who's uh not stressed lars he he never looks
stressed he always looks like bewildered is the
best way to put it well then i can't tell
is he always stress or is he never stressed
one of these situations where it's one of
the other because he does look bewildered he
has he's wide-eyed trying to see through these
positions and look at this opening once again
we have a wild start to the game when lars
has the white pieces so when roberto's
white we get some calm approach maybe let's
trade some pieces i'm gonna try to outplay you
from large like no chill let's just go for a pawn
launch and see what happens yeah like uh i think
when lars is playing he really tests the chess.com
opening theory book um and he really is trying to
find out whether chess.com has a name for all
the openings that he's that he's bringing out
here like g4 uh all right chess.com what's this
one called that's actually really funny and
at a certain point there's no name you're
like all right that's the lars that's
that's it'll have to be it'll have to be and what
is going on here because black is trying to crack
through on the queen side and it looks like
white at some point will play on the king side
but white can actually castle king side black has
no pieces over there so even though you pushed
your pawns to g5 and h4 cast on king side should
be safe for white and castle kingside for black
could get you checkmated yeah you can castle
uh king side despite the pawns being pushed
yeah i don't know about that one giving of the f6
square man that seems risky let's let's go with
risky yeah we'll call it risky call it even um
he does castle kingside despite you know knight
getting in we understand the movie h6 it's like
hey he wants to take and after pawn takes he's
got the the open file but the moment that knight
is covering the h2 square and i was about to say
knight g4 also covers h2 and prepares what he
is dying to play which is knight to e5 followed
by maybe f4 wow if you could get all those moves
in that's just probably strategically game over
i don't see a way to stop it well knight d7
stops knight to e5 but can you start taking on
the queen side like i feel like that side of the
board some kind of take on i don't really want to
take on c5 though see that's the annoying thing
because i want to open the whole queen side but i
want to keep control over an e5 square and
i know i can't get everything that i want so
need to time this kind of thing correctly i think
taking a b4 might make some sense um you know if
the pawn takes back you've got the c file and
if the knight takes back you temporarily get
the e5 square i don't know if you can make use of
that though and instead lars plays the com rookie
one but there could be an e4 in the near future
trying to open up the position against the king
on e7 although wait a second is that bishop
on b7 so there must be some tactical sequence
and i see the eval bar just jumped out of my
periphery there and now knight takes d4 maybe
yeah d4 is is loose he's gonna start by um trying
to open more lines with pawn takes on c3 but uh
yeah you immediately jump to that bishop on
b7 and say look the knight's in the way got
a hanging rook on or loose rook on e4 take that
knight and drop it wherever you want basically
and yet taking the pawn d4 in the process
looks great and actually looks just unstoppable
and there's lars sitting and thinking but maybe
a little bit too late you should have thought
before playing e4 spent only 1.5 seconds playing
the movie e4 and now he's deep in the think tank
trying to figure out is there a way to survive
this and it doesn't look like the answer is yes
and that's that's such a common chess player
thing it's like you play really quick and then
once you've played too quick that you know you
might be losing it's like okay well let's spend
the time and try to get out of this whoops yeah
queen takes c3 which gives it the d4 pawn for free
uh knight takes d4 the brook and e4 is hanging
where do you even move that rook i think is he
playing this no is he playing his sack um
well he's plenty of sax something i guess
is fair to say but i was wondering
about rook takes d4 and knight takes d4
probably necessary but then we trick bishops on
g2 and i think that white's king is in worse shape
even though black's king is in the center yeah
temporarily after bishop g2 king g2 you have a
threat of knight c6 to win the whole game but
it's it's super temporary you know you make a
move like roxy at the end and then you say oh
well my one thread is out the window and lars is
good yeah lars is trying to figure this out
here but it's too late and roberto still looks
really stressed like somebody hit that guy some
fresh air yeah he is racking his brain right now
it's it's incredible like they're they're
both obviously incredibly focused but
roberto just looks like he had a death in the
family or something like it's it's it's looks
serious it's just how much he wants to avoid these
tactical games i get the feeling and he said that
in previous matches where you know his style is to
trade against the end game play solidly and he has
no choice playing against lars and the thing is
it may be a 3-1 lead after this game it's still
so early and in the back of his head's like wait a
second i got to play bullet against this guy he's
fast he's sharp he's tactical and so he needs to
save his nerves for when the moments really call
for them and that will be the quicker time
controls and and you know we uh obviously
probably do a good job of underselling how strong
roberto is at calculations um and tactics because
you know he he doesn't hang in games with
uh you know very strong tactical players
for no reason at all like his king's on e7
and somehow he's the one getting the upper
hand in these uh these skirmishes so definitely
a very accomplished uh player in his own right
and able to calculate as well or often better than
his opponents e4 was a slip up by lars and look
how quickly and look how efficiently that move
was punished down on the clock is lars and down
on the board absolutely that is something that
is good to point out it's not the players either
are bad at what the other prefers it's just a
preference a stylistic choice so lars can play end
games at a very high level he's an international
master for a reason and highly rated but it's not
his first choice if you say let's get a position
on move one without queens on the border with
two queens on the board he's taking two queens
on the board and on the other hand roberto saying
oh queen's off the board yeah let's do that thing
let's get to an end game so it's just a clash of
styles and right now lars is down well he's half
the time that roberto does less than half and
it's still looking good for black no way to break
through for white no attack that i can see and so
it does look like roberto should continue to take
this game but all of a sudden the knights on e5
maybe there's queen f4 to f6 black does need to be
a bit careful here thankfully for roberto he has
the time to calculate yeah and um that rook on e4
is there's so many sequences here like the rook on
h5 is loose from the bishop uh c6 is now targeted
square for the knight to jump in supported by
the bishop on f3 knight d5 looks to me like a
nice inter mezzo move because you hit the queen
and the queen seemingly has to move to a square
that watches that g5 pawn but it doesn't and
looking at rook g5 and wondering what i'm missing
uh the answer is probably nothing and where's that
king going the knight on e5 is also yeah wait
you're just losing everything's just hanging
right that was a slip up and actually if
we just show really quickly i think that
if lars like queen to d2 instead of queen of b3
there he like had a chance in this game because
if he had played queen d2 the pawns protected
that rook's under attack on h5 the a5 pawn is
under attack so the queen is doing all the work
and black's position isn't that simple to figure
out so i think that was a missed opportunity by
lars it was just not a great game from him we've
of course seen much better and maybe he just
felt out of it but amman before we had to break
at our halftime break in the five minute portion
what are your thoughts about the match so far
of course roberto leads three to one but how
have you seen this match come along thus far
uh i think i'm seeing it develop almost what i
would expect we see that roberto is the higher
rated blitz player and we've also seen from
match's previous that lars generates a lot of his
points from the bullet section and i think he's
also the type of player that because of his style
you know not the most sound openings maybe
slightly dubious it fits his style but
i think that takes a little bit of time to
get going you know you're not just gonna
show up to the the match and just play brilliancy
right right off the bat so i think that type of
style takes a little bit of time to get going
and uh you know he's obviously hoping to do a
lot better in the bullet so it actually is
progressing much as i would expect i don't
think either player can be too disappointed at
the moment but lars does need to find his footing
from these openings agreed partner sometimes our
blessing is our curse and the tactical prowess of
lars oscar hogg it can come back to bite him
when he gets too tactical he gets too rushed
to break the position open and that's what we saw
here in this last game on that note we are going
to take a break and return we'll have more from
chess.com's i am now gm speeches championship
so
well we know there are two people paying close
attention to this match it's not you and i am on
it is greg and levy because the winner of that
match takes on the winner of this one and well
what do you make of monday's matchup between greg
and levy both of whom have been impressive thus
far levy's matchups being quite close to against
the semi-finals and greg having the odds match
in the first round and then against costia just
a three-point victory for him so who do you see
as the favorite in monday's matchup well i think
uh if we're talking about who has the momentum
right now it's gotta be levy roseman aka gotham
chess with you know his his recent uh performances
in uh chess.com blitz and bullets especially he's
gonna come in i think the higher rated player in
uh maybe both categories um robert
so it definitely looks like on paper
you know levy the levy train is is in full
force and i just have i'm having a flashback
right now to his last match against the eric
rosen which was you know prime time special so
obviously excited to get into more stuff like
that that was one of my favorite events to
commentate ever that was so much fun we had
the call together we were losing our minds
the players were nervous and we will see levy move
on to face greg who of course has been a mainstay
a strong blitz player for so many years however
we're in the middle of this game we see a repeat
of the third game of the match roberto going
back to this line in the queen's game decline
playing bishop e2 trying to leave black with
the isolated pawn but we didn't really like
what roberto got in that game what do you think
he'll do differently it's a good question because
uh for the opening moves and this is sort of
proving my point i don't think there's much to
change so up till now it's the exact same game
um b3 and bishop b2 is something that i thought
he would do you know multiple points during that
last game or the last time we saw this opening
he's actually brought his knight from the center
back to f3 which is a very strange move to me
yeah that's is strange but it's just
trying to avoid trades i guess and
yeah it doesn't feel right but he's protecting
his king and now he puts his bishop on a3 with
tempo so i'm sort of at a loss of what's happening
here but i don't mind it for either side honestly
yeah bishop a3 is with tempo but when you're
attacking that rook on f8 i mean every single
time black plays this opening he's going to grab
that row from f8 and put it on e8 so neither side
is you know too phased by by that little maneuver
bishop a3 rookie is exactly what lars would do
anyway look for this light squared bishop to make
an appearance either on you know f5 or the more
aggressive g4 um but bishop f5 played looking to
control the center and uh rook might appear on c8
i mean you pointed it out and the eval bar backs
you up 0.00 basically both sides doing well here
and i like the bishop on a3 because it takes
away queen d6 which is often a nuisance
setting up the battery for a checkmatic attack
knight e4 the knight just went to a4 so i might
as well take this square that's available to me
and now knight c5 let's trade knights and when
you see these trades being offered the palm b7
is under attack so black has to react in some way
but white is happy about this you want to blockade
the isolated pawn so you want to make sure that
black can't push d5 to d4 and if that bishop gets
to c5 well for sure you're not pushing that bomb
right yeah if the the pieces trade the bishop
blockades on d4 i think that roberto is
uh he's gonna be pretty happy with that now
the pawn is hit on e7 and you know an attempt
to guard that with rook b8 might also be met by
uh knight b7 and i'll show you right here like
uh this is a very typical uh maneuver you play
rook ba thinking you're covering the threat
and the guy just does it anyway and i don't think
there's anything more disheartening in chess than
protecting a threat and then your opponent just
does it anyway so right that's why he captured
they always told me to look for undefended
pieces i defend it but then it's a secondary
layer right you take the pawn to remove the
defense of the knight and as you get better
and better chess you need to be on the lookout
for these things and well look at this oh okay i
didn't like that move i'm on because i thought
rook e6 first i was about to say a rook lift
people missed brook lifts all the time and
lars i think should have started with rook e6
and then figure out does the rook go to g6 does it
go to h6 but either way the queen can join later
but the rook now cannot join because the queen's
in the way yeah that's a great point um starting
with the rook i mean basically take that rook on
e8 place it on g6 or h6 right now that's where it
wants to be and the bishop is doing a great job
on e4 contributing to the attack f3 g2 but also
contributing to defending that isolated pawn in
the center so it's a great anchor if you want to
kick that bishop out at any point you know bishop
d3 in the future bishop f3 you can also just leave
the bishop there in lars's position and say hey
take me bring my my isolated pawn even closer to
your king and yeah knight d4 was a very good move
because now in the event of some kind of queen h4
why can i move f4 so that knight on f3 while
it was defending the h2 pawn directly it didn't
allow white to push pawns forward and you may say
wait pushing pawns forward in front of your king
that sounds bad but it also allows your other
pieces to defend for example the queen on d2
will defend g2 once the pawn moves
out the way in the bishop as well so
i actually think that rook e6 first and we
talked about this leading with rope was good
knight d4 a fantastic response by roberto yep and
the time again seems to be uh the classic case of
the guy who's the better bullet player is lower on
time i don't this is becoming like a widespread uh
i guess phenomenon that the the better you are at
bullet the more comfortable you are letting your
clock tick down because your you know two minutes
to a good bullet player is like i got extra time
you know i this is too much time whereas
uh you know roberto who's obviously a great
bullet player in his own right but probably isn't
counting on scoring as many points in that section
as lars could be in this match you know he's
always been up on time from what i've seen so far
yeah good start to this match from roberto in
this game no exception to that i was starting to
wonder i was kind of daydreaming about some greek
gift sacrifices now it's not going to be possible
because white is going to play f4 i believe
to cut off that bishop but i was just thinking
was there a bishop h2 and then a
bishop g2 and all that kind of stuff
i don't have the answer to my own question
i'm guessing the answer is no because lars
the great tactician he is would have played it if
it worked out yeah it's uh something that he would
be looking for at every turn and you mentioned
the move f4 there it is on the board and this
can be a really tough move to face because you
know what a lot of times in positions like this
robert it lack is required to make a pivot from
full-on attack to oh i'm actually now going to
transition into just playing this game normally
maybe capturing on d4 going rook c8 you know
nothing nothing too special and that might not
be in the style that lars wants to play and this
pawn e3 that looks like a backwards pawn but hey
there's a bishop on c5 so that pawn is actually
very well defended and bishop d4 piled pressure
against this pawn c6 there's no attack that i see
at least not at the moment for black and so for
white you can start attacking and putting that in
air quotes on the queen side because there's some
weak pawns that you can try to put threats on and
win yeah bishop d4 i mean queen g6 piling up uh
on g2 so speaking of threats take the air quotes
off because that's an important one and bishop
f3 looking to trade some pieces however with all
these bishops come off i feel like white has to be
pretty happy with that development rook c6 there
goes that pawn just down the spot i think you can
take it there maybe i'm overlooking some tactical
sequence with bishop f3 or in queen b no i don't
think that works i think rook takes c6 is just
a pawn you can grab and that's a very important
pawn it's not just the material but then white
can have a free attempt at a pass pawn on
the queen side with a4 b5 in the future
and keep in mind uh you know something like bishop
f3 rook takes f3 there would be um you know bishop
takes d4 might be an idea to take on e3 and fork
the king and queen here is a discovered attack but
the rook on f3 perfectly defends that so there's
just no tricks as you brought up it it almost
feels like lars played that move instinctively
thinking that there would be some of those tricks
queen b1 bishop takes d4 but because there weren't
any um in the position and it doesn't appear to be
roberto called that bluff immediately with rook
c6 now lars is fumbling for the next the next
move here and you get frustrated when you overlook
these kind of simple moves oh my pawn was defended
by the queen the bishop got in the queen's path
now i just dropped the pawn and he's down almost
two minutes he only has a half minute himself
and this is looking like it should be roberto's
game but it's not over right black can play on
here it is upon deficit that's no fun but just
keep going and you need to play more quickly
because otherwise you're losing the clock as well
yeah and rook c8 um i'll just point out you know
rook takes a6 for example uh you can see that
evaluation bar just uh say goodbye as rook
c2 and you're threatening rook takes g2
and coming in with a very lethal uh check meeting
so pattern can't allow that rook to infiltrate so
do you take on c8 perhaps and just start trading
those bishops off is that a way to go though rook
c2 is still going to be a bit of a nuisance maybe
you trade on c8 and like rook seem one yourself
because of black's back rank
checkmate problems but okay roberto
answers the question i would i would trade on
e4 and then you can trade on c8 and go rook c1
or you can just go roxy one but trading on c8 and
rook c1 um does seem that seem pretty reasonable
though if you trade on c8 rook c2 isn't
an immediate threat which is funny because
it looks like it just wins the game because
white has this rook c1 resource so it's just
funny how these things can happen i just wouldn't
even want to think tactically so like rook c8
uh i'll show rook uh see it rook c8 and then you
know imagine white just tries to debate him it
just goes like h3 and you know rook c2 rook c1 is
uh is robert's idea the idea of course you can't
take the queen he's a back rank mate so you just
want to see these things and just remind yourself
hey wait there's no luft for the black king so
there could be a background checkmate and actually
this is a good illustration of that because the
e3 pawn if you take with the queen on d4 it looks
like you could win the pawn e3 you cannot there's
background checkmate but i like what roberto is
doing thinking at this moment i'm actually not
sure what to take with probably the pawn takes
is better because if you take with the queen
there's a queen b1 check queen takes a2 check
that looks like a lot to calculate so pawn takes
d4 is probably the best move i just like that
roberto spending some time but he's about to dip
maybe into too much time queen b1 queen takes a2
with check would probably be enough for me to
not play that on the spot um and he does it wow
i was with you i was not giving away that pawn
i mean listen it's not a not a mistake but uh
not a huge blender but i don't i think he takes
was preferable and watch out now because queen
f1 is a big threat so king f2 played and where's
that king maybe he's not running anywhere maybe
he's accepting that it'll be a repetition maybe
they're both accepting that it'll be a repetition
if you're lars you must be thrilled you'd straight
up blundered upon c6 that was not a sacrifice that
was a blunder we saw by his reaction and yet he
still was able to hold things together and he
was down almost two minutes on the clock yeah no
that's a great point and there's a reason why uh
one of these players is shaking their
head at the result not both of them
yes and he's still mad he needs to we all need
to do this when we play a match we need to
get over our previous games the problem
is in a tournament you have a full day
right if you're playing a classical chess
tournament you lose a game or you draw a game
you're winning you're frustrated you say i'll eat
i'll sleep prepare for a next game now it's like
next game going yeah you know snap and you have to
get right back with it and look at lars he doesn't
give you any time to breathe he is threatening
checkmate of course roberta's not going to allow
the checkmate but do i take on g5 and then allow
that bishop into the game and castle's queen side
or did i play g6 which was the choice but now
there are all these potential dark square holes
on the king side so no rest for the tactically
weary roberto molina yeah and it's basically just
uh lars he has this style that puts on relentless
pressure in the opening um this line is clearly
something that lars is familiar with it's a little
bit off the beaten path um just going back and
showing this move bishop e2 is not one of the most
common moves here i think this is an important
game an important moment in this match because
we all know um from previous matches with roberto
how fond or not fond he is of the carol khan
he he plays it as his main weapon and if
lars gets you know great positions or starts
crushing him with this opening that could do a lot
to roberto's confidence and uh he mentioned that
in the post-game interview of his last match that
because his opponent was able to get such a good
position against uh his karo khan speaking about
lawrence trent uh he was actually thrown off
during the match he was indeed and right now
he has what looks like a dream position whenever
somebody establishes d4 and e5 pawns you want to
break down the pawn chain with the c5 move and
he's accomplished that and knight c6 is the next
move the thing about this i i see the evaluation
bar saying black is heavily favored and roberto
has plenty of time he's good experience and he
is a great player but what i think about where
is that king going for black if white can somehow
maintain the pressure then that king never finds
true safety and even if the objective evaluation
is oh black's doing great practically speaking
you always feel that not in your stomach of wait
a second there could be some kind of sacrifice or
some checkmating attack and so roberto needs to
figure that out yeah and speaking of sacrifice
um you know i'll just show one of the common
ones that you're always thinking of h6 you
know if you play that without thinking too much
well hang on knight takes e6 is always a big idea
um and queen takes g6 to follow up bishop takes
h6 is in the position he might just run the f pawn
queen takes e6 as well like this is how positions
like that fall apart uh fall apart for black
that's true and so roberto moves his queen out to
b6 i like that move a lot hitting the knight on
b5 hitting protecting i should say the pawn on d4
and now a4 is played so a6 would seem the logical
follow-up and white is going to play knight d6
check so you've encouraged that knight in here
and i've always found these positions amman
to be extremely challenging to evaluate i get
the feeling oh black should be better you have a
pawn and then you're like wait how do i move from
here i can't castle queen side f7 falls i can't
castle king side there will be some big attack
especially with those exposed dark squares do i
play e5 which for now is safe but a rookie one
happens and maybe bishop moves in f4 breaks open
the position i'm never sure what move to play
even if i feel that the position should be good
for black and if if people don't believe you what
was funny is that while you were saying i don't
actually know how to evaluate these the evaluation
bar wasn't sure how to evaluate this it started
going up and down without any moves being played
like it even takes the engine time to adjust the
positions like this because of everything that
robert pointed out there i mean the king we need a
decision which way are you going e5 in the center
and after rookie one is it gonna be something
like f6 allowing the knight into e6 it just looks
it looks like too much you gotta gotta put the
king somewhere yeah i grimace at the thought of
f6 uh if the knight coming to e6 scares me then
i go to c7 wow grimace away knight e6 king f7
and uh that wow that is impressive that
knight is very scary and 96 just king f7
and the knight goes to cease i don't know
how to evaluate this position i feel like
you know i i know i can see the evaluation bar off
the side over here when i tilt my head this way
i see that black is doing well but i would roberto
doesn't know that he's trying to figure this out
he probably thinks okay i have a good chances here
but he doesn't know with any degree of certainty
that black is in the driver's seat and i don't
know what move should be played even if when i
do see that the evaluation is good for black is
it king f7 is it okay king of sun was played and
queen h3 and i see the evil bar kind of going
up a little bit for once i don't know what to do
i i have no idea it's that kind of wild position
i think i would play the move i would not take the
bishop that's for sure that scares me too much
maybe i should do that i'm not doing that the
queen on h3 lines up against that knight on d7 uh
rook would have the open e file that looks pretty
scary i just also don't know what else to play
though yeah maybe i mean there's at least knight
g5 after taking on f4 with the queen getting right
involved in the position that looks like it cannot
be good that's no [ __ ] uh it's probably i'm
guessing it's one of those positions that's
gonna be like oh it's a draw because of some
weird you know saving idea for black that just
forces white to take a repetition it's like one
of those types but it doesn't look good i could
also see why just winning in the next few moves
what other moves come to mind besides about like
i want to move my knight somewhere okay oh look at
the evil bar i saw the skyrocket so i was going to
say move the knight from c6 as he did somewhere
and then knight c7 i want to play queen d6
so that that's the general idea is that you know
all saka in exchange to get rid of that pawn
however right now i don't think it's an exchange
and bishop takes e5 i don't even think it's going
to be night move at all oh my goodness knight g5
he wants he wants knight g5 he could probably even
play rook take okay not probably just does it
just does it don't need to tell him what to do
and d6 queenie is you have to play that move yeah
because pawn takes e5 with knight g5 check coming
your king is getting mated in the near future so
i think queen takes d6 and just put your hands
together uh talk to uh kaiser there and say please
help me survive this game because you're oh no way
well no that's who you need to talk to right now
oh knight g5 not the move you know that means f4
was the move like bringing in another f4 f5
what a okay but queen e6 like i will i don't
think i'll be satisfied it must be rook f eight
no rook f8 loses immediately yeah the queen e7
like i said i am not convinced that black survives
this so if he he does he deserves everything
he's 18 seconds left knight c6 like queen d7 the
only check where's f7 oh finish did you think
about that but i like the evaluation bar it's like
doing jump rope knight f7 check i like queen e7
because you kept the square open for that knight
takes e5 check just keep taking things with check
where's that king going after king 60 of knight
g4 there has to be a mate here of course king f6
there's maybe f4 as well oh gosh yeah okay knight
g4 i mean i actually don't see a mate just yet
so it looks like there has to be something
what do you think about h3 that's just some move
like that i like that i like h3 especially because
roberto is 10 seconds left it's 10 seconds that's
the other thing is that practically it's winning
as well an h3 queen g7 queen h6 you protect
them that's oh that's super clever i like that
i i like h3 for that because i was even thinking
about queen g7 right now as i'm you know hey take
a step forward if you're if you're that uh you're
that ballsy but i think h3 is probably the way to
go look at lars eyes by the way yeah he played
h3 yeah great move this evaluation bar is not
no idea what it's doing it's been at the
bar too long it's got it's got to go home
queen g7 threatening mate and one queen
h6 and after queen g5 i'm sure it's knight
f6 check which uh okay knight of six
where's the mate though so knight f6 g5
knight f6 king g5 f4 king f5 g4 king e6 oh a
queen d7 decides oh my gosh we oh my gosh well
wait robert just one second by the way he's
gonna lose him oh he doesn't lose some time
f4 check here's the mate coming exactly what
we were talking about oh and f4 king h4 king h2
that's beautiful that's so beautiful that's filthy
oh my gosh there's nothing you can do about it oh
this is just g3 here it comes king of oh he lost
some time but we have to show look at lars's face
oh my gosh if he got that move off and i'll
go back and show you guys so many cool mates
there in that position so um before we get into
the next game we got a show king h4 king h2 uh
if nothing else robert tons of style points
sacking your queen and checkmating with a pawn
the knight the f pawn everybody working the king's
involved you don't even need that rook over there
and the other one we were looking at was king f5
g4 check king's only got one square queen d7 check
king takes knight and then another pawn
checkmate that's just you don't you don't
get attacks that you know capitulate with pawn
checkmates uh all the time robert no that was
a gorgeous tactical sequence and you could tell
that lars was feeling it and honestly what we're
talking about we know the evaluation bar at first
was saying black is doing well and i'm sure if you
just switch on the engine look at the suggestions
there are ideas and moves for black to survive
but practically speaking it's just beyond
difficult in a blitz game so lars really
earned that one and for roberto i don't think
you have to stray from your karakana i mean he
was doing well he's going to get a break after
this portion i would just quickly you know text
a friend or turn on the engine and to review that
game okay i could have actually survived and had
a good position if i'd done these two things then
you feel better about going right back to that con
robert would after getting checkmated by a pawn
immediately text a friend hey i need emotional
support and i rely on my friends i try to be
open i talk through my feelings i'm on yeah your
support support system for those tough checkmates
it's good to have one of those around yep we all
need friends and lars by the way he's is he up
he's a pawn in this position yes but there's a
bishop pair that's staring towards black's king
yeah it does not it actually looks like if you
reverse the names that's the position i would
expect them to have um lars has actually been the
the greedy one here he's gobbled that center pawn
and you talked about rook lifts well how
about how about an assisted rook lift
i actually was going to say i loved the move
bishop e4 that was a really good defensive move
but i liked the response instead of taking on e4
doing anything you just try to improve your rook
but knight f5 is so frustrating because now your
rook lifts don't look quite as good the d4 pawn
needs some attention and oh how to proceed g4 for
white that looks quite risky but i could see that
panning out and watch out for d5 at some moment as
well opening that bishop up so just like the other
game the one we just saw this is a situation where
sure black is probably having a healthy position
according to the engine but practically speaking
there's so many tactics to keep an eye out for
and whenever the evaluation uh is around equal
guys like whatever is right in the middle of
the board 0.00 but one side is down an entire
pawn it means that the other side has exactly
enough compensation for the game to be level and
in positions like that usually you want to be the
side down upon um you know if the game is equal
but you're down upon it means you probably have a
great position and i'm a huge fan of the d5 punch
in and then loosen up that f5 knight and get like
a rook f3 rook takes f6 and you can immediately go
get these like super dangerous checkmating ideas
yeah i'm with you there and i like queen
c2 just keeping an eye on the a4 pawn
why did black play the queen d8 sure rook d8
can happen but also that pawn was under attack
bishop a3 is an idea because that rook on f8 isn't
so happy there and b5 by lars i think bishop a3
will be met by knight d6 and looks like
black can hold on to the material for now
yeah even still it looks like the type of
position where even if bishop a3 won the rook
you'd almost be unhappy to do it because you know
you you see a position like this and all you want
to do is go rook f3 d5 you know sack for something
on the king side here and i actually think the
move b5 by lars is very resourceful a very strong
move like if that gets taken twice uh the reason
that roberto is thinking so long i'll just show
you let's say we capture everything um that
square on d5 is what it's all about and i wouldn't
be surprised if knight d5 first instead of queen
b5 was playable but you get the idea the knight
sinks in and that bishop on b2 robert is not
participating anymore and roberta did play
bishop a3 so uh we have similar names and
he goes well we actually have the same name just
from different places and so bishop a3 played the
rook on f8's in trouble and he just takes back
on c4 after lars talks the d5 square is blacks
however you have to sit passively for the
time being and there's that first rook left
and don't be surprised if the second one joins
the party with rook d3 and swinging it over to
f3 or g3 probably one of the funniest things that
i see in chess is when when you double rook lift
and then somebody threatens back rank mate it's
like wait i can't get out of it my rooks are
blocking my two pawns so that's the one thing to
watch out for when you double rook lift is that
a simple back rank threat can sometimes just be
like force mate that's true and i'm not sure you
actually have anywhere to go with that second rook
perhaps one rook can do the job and bishop c1 at
some point comes to mind i like knight e5 bringing
your piece back towards the enemy king and i was
saying bishop c1 to sacrifice an h6 but if i move
bishop c1 then knight frees up from e7 so it's so
tricky position where black has an extra pawn
white has the current initiative but if you're
not quick it feels like black is able to get out
of this and claim an advantage not just a decent
position yeah and you know i i'm looking at the
move f6 now that it's available the knight moved
out of the way f6 kicks the knight on e5 out it
also opens up just generally speaking you know
another avenue for the black queen maybe queen
g6 especially bishop c1 would be a consideration
agreed f6 such a difficult move for newer players
less experienced players to go for because they're
told never to push in front of their king
but then knight e5 is just frustrating black
and if that queen can get to g6 as you mentioned
or the rook up to f7 to help defend it brings in
more resources for the black king so right now
this is the tough question i'm on where to go
because white's pieces seem pretty optimally
placed perhaps the rook on d1 would like to
go up to g3 but you were just talking about how
that could lead to a background checkmate that you
for example actually rook d3 rook b8 there's
already threats of queen takes a4 in the
near future because of this very background
checkmate so i'll actually show that that's a
good point if you swing the the rooks over there
queen takes a4 as robert pointed out this is
exactly what i was talking about these rooks that
make it so that the king can't escape it's like
a suffocation yeah you can't go all in and well
roberto plays rook g3 and lars plays f6 so we're
right on the mark amani and knight g4 i
think the threat is clear knight takes
h6 maybe he'll blunder that and if the knight
moves from e7 the rook on f8 is under attack so
not that easy to make a move and he just says ha
i'm cool let's slide the king to h8 no problem yep
yeah now knight f5 is not quite possible because
bishop takes f8 followed by bishop takes g7 with a
check um h6 though threat renewed and like i just
pointed out knight f5 is not exactly possible so
maybe your queen h5 type of move where you use the
fact that the queen is opened up but there could
even be a knight takes h6 there like giving up the
knight to play rook h3 after there are a bunch of
tactics to figure out thankfully for lars he has
a lot of time two minutes 26 seconds and just
plays rook f7 look at that knight f5 is such a big
threat now that the pin has been removed from the
game um wow knight f5 is so tough to deal with and
not know if i for sure is about to happen has to
well he's thinking which means he might take
that pawn in a4 which i wasn't even looking
at until he started thinking like why could he
be thinking here now he plays knight of five
and now he'll take on a4 i think so now uh
e6 falls but d4 is hanging everything falls
yeah the thing is the attack white is kind
of like queen side bishop kingside knight
rooks are like half in the middle half attacking
every piece is kind of doing a different thing
in this position robert so yeah queen a4 as you
mentioned queen takes d4 it feels like white's
game falls apart here especially with 20 seconds
great response to bishop c5 and queen d7 quickly
dropping that back i just don't see how white can
attack the knight on f5 the problem for white in
part is you need a pawn and an iron g4 at the
same time you need to kick this knight out of f5
and you can't do it so rook a3 probably
a good positional move just trying to
double and attack that pawn on a6 and maybe that's
what roberto needs to do is give up on the attack
and just go for that pawn we're gonna see
at some point like an h3 just a move from uh
roberto if he doesn't have a move he's probably
just going to throw that in 93 looking to trade
a6 pawn being pressured i think roberto is doing
a good job with 10 seconds um but lars has the
advantage here no doubt and nice quick reply
there after knight f4 threatening mates on g2 just
f3 blocking the queen and now this a6 pawn that's
falling right queen d3 and if you lose that pawn
your king isn't perfectly safe and you only have
one extra pawn for black so i actually think that
roberto is doing a really amazing job at fending
off the immediate threats and then trying to
honestly among what i guess i want to say is
changing from aggressive plans to defensive
that's a really hard switch to turn on and he
did that mid game with no time on his clock
agree agreeing queen e4 he might even be looking
for more here just forcing the queen tray taking
a6 next and on 92 check look at that king f2
just making sure you don't drop the d4 pawn
very very quick now a6 drops um one thing to
watch out for is maybe knight d3 um black is
still up uh upon which is why his position
is still favored here and wow look at that
look at that how quick was that sequence
and i think that's a fantastic find by
lars super impressive it really is now d6
is falling so black is going up two pawns
the e4 pawn light square you have a dark sword
bishop not going to be easy to defend that one
after knight g5 kind of sequence this should be
winning objectively for lars and on the clock
as well c4 great follow-up move and you'll
find that the pieces just invade here knight g5
is pretty much the end of the game taking
the e-pawn and i think he sees that now
same idea and we'll actually get one more game
in this time control when this one concludes
and for lars he is the momentum for roberto
he played really well at the start of this
match and he's playing well it's not like
that's the problem it's just he got down
on the clock and he was down a pawn and he
couldn't quite figure out how to proceed
and lars came came right back in this uh in this
match it's actually been rookie for maybe just
trade okay i like rookies there it is yeah
yeah but this has been a big comeback from
uh lars since the break uh robert he basically
came out of the break at a different person
he's improved the i don't want to say new but
definitely the improved compared to the first
four games of the match so lars is ready to go
and this is a bad sign for fans of roberto molina
because we know how strong lars is in bullitt
roberto also very strong but in the history
in the first two rounds of this tournament i
think lars like a 15 to five score something
like that something crazy but it is three and a
half three and a half tied match we have another
karo khan this will be the final game of the five
minute time patrol and amman do you expect to see
some kind of crazy position like we
just saw two games ago yes yes i do
i think lars is not going to change a line where
he had like and lesbian lars saw those checkmates
at the end of that last game he just didn't
get a chance to play them because his opponent
flagged so if you have a game like that uh trust
me there's there's a part of your brain that says
i'll just repeat it and we'll play the exact
same game and i'll checkmate him this time
you know he's he's going to go back to those
positions because look how well they worked it's
no longer a choice you just have to do it wait
queen h6 see bishop we just saw that position
i'm not you know he's he's just checking maybe
he might actually just take a draw why not he's
made a big comeback already i think he probably
evaluates his bullet chances as pretty good wow
okay well he takes the draw by repetition and i
like that decision for both of them for roberto
you score half point after two consecutive defeats
for lars you can say wait a sec i know what i did
landed me a victory a smashing victory with a
checkmate but perhaps there's something there's
a flaw in here and to have the self-awareness
to question your decision say you know i won but
that looked a bit sketchy let me actually
go look that up i think for both players
this was a very mature moment yeah i
think that um roberto doesn't have a
as much of a choice um being black and also after
queen h6 you sort of have to bring the bishop back
so um i think this was an interesting decision
but i don't think it's that crazy as i said lars
scores a lot of his points in the bullet portion
can't forget roberto has like a crazy high bullet
rating like i'm pretty sure he came in at like
28.50 or something uh ridiculous last time so
do not think that this is like a lars gets the
bullet and wins the match type of thing but it's
just that's where he has gotten his points in
the past that looks as though he's comfortable
with the draw get to the next portion and get
to the bullet probably the best lars has done
in the first time patrol with that it's in the
books we will take a break and when we come back
we'll come back for more of this 4-4 match-up
between lars oscar hogg and roberto molina
so
and we are back ready for more from roberto and
lars amon amman 4-4 score lars has the momentum
he's won a few of the last i think two and a half
last three games to even this match up who do you
think is happier that the break just took place
uh it's a good question it's sort of funny because
we don't see a lot of breaks um happen right after
a peaceful result like that it seemed like both
guys are actually pretty reasonably happy to go
to break but obviously i think lars is going to
be very very happy in general to be done with the
five minute portion i think when the time control
gets shorter his style gets better um and that
uh you know he likes to go for these speculative
sacks and the you know slightly dubious openings
and i'm here for it i think it's a great style
especially in online chess and i think it works
better when your opponent has less time to sort
of calculate everything out and figure out
exactly what you're up to and we're back
in the games here oh an e3 we're not getting the
vienna with e4 we need to get in the title of this
opening right three nights vienna quiet variation
so quiet variation i think we know who chose that
one and it is roberto once again and by the way
i looked up their bullet ratings during the break
lars is 2820 bullet roberto is 28.01 or something
like that so they are about even in terms of
bullet so it's going to be a tight match up to
the very end yeah it is going to be a heavyweight
matchup in the bullet portion right now
though we've got the three plus one section so
i would say a time control that the players
always feel a little bit more comfortable with
there's still that plus one robert but three
minutes is what everyone is used to playing online
that's true for sure and it's what everyone plays
and the ignorant makes a difference it allows
players who make flag in other circumstances gives
them some time to build and here lars plays for e5
so roberto got an e4 but after dropping his bishop
back to d3 and lars plays e5 and to my eyes d5 is
the natural response try to keep that bishop on
b7 locked in that bishop on c1 can go to g5 in the
near future i think that white's spatial advantage
is not to be taken for granted but what do you
think lars anticipates from this and he wants to
blockade the deep on first but i still like white
yeah white's position looks good it's that bishop
on b7 because especially in this position there's
some a little bit of a different dynamic that
you have to watch that a pawn so you can't just
bring the bishop back to c8 and reroute it to
another diagonal like you normally would and
if you play a5 you're giving up a lot a lot of
light squares in your position so i understand
lars is coming with the knight to d6 he's going
for the trades but very simply you can pile up
pressure on the c file here for white and maybe
even go for something like a5 bring the rook to c1
slow gameplay knight h4 into into f5 is another
idea to try to play on both sides of the board
but i i echo with what you're saying here this
looks very comfortable for roberto um right out
of the gate it's funny you just mentioned a5
and i was thinking how both players probably
want to play that and now black can play a5 which
means that there's no pawn hanging on the square
the downside of playing a5 you give up control
of the light square so knight d6 first but once
again i know white went work a1 to b1 but i do
believe that a5 still is a pretty promising move
from white's point of view yeah if you wait
and play b4 first for example um they might
follow bishop e3 and then maybe a5 from black as
an option just to take control of all those dark
squares on the queen side we're definitely going
to see that after the trade i don't see another
appealing move besides a5 gives you the c5 square
for your knight allows your rook on 8 to be more
active and if white plays b5 after black plays
a5 you shut down the queen side and it's black
who controls the pawn breaks on the other side
of the board so lars does play a5 it taking makes
sense he can bring a rook to c1 uh for roberto
he'd simply use bishop b5 but knight c5 would
be my very quick response i think this position is
easier to play for black what do you think i'm on
yep agreed not a big fan of the b4 move for white
so that's what i would have omitted going forward
if i was playing the position but knight d2 he's
swinging that knight over whether it's to b3 or c4
um i think that uh lars has a very easy game
though he can slide the rook to a8 from f8
he can now we talked about that bishop couldn't
move earlier now there's no uh a6 pawn well look
at that move bishop a6 there's also bishop c8 to
d7 same idea it's funny i knew you're about to
say bishop a6 because you said he could now and
then he made the move so i knew you were saying
it before he played it and that bishop can even
come to d3 plant that bishop there the e4 pawn
starts feeling a bit uncomfortable the rook on a5
is actually a strong piece that knight on d6 if
you're not careful we'll hop into c4 if you move
that knight from d2 so i think bishop d3 and maybe
f5 to follow breaking open the king side instead
lars plays g6 a bit of a quieter move and now
knight b3 we mentioned this idea for white so i
thought that you need to be a bit quicker for lars
and well i'm registering maybe neither of us need
to move too quickly well it's the quiet variation
robert both players are echoing that here with g6
f3 just some slow building moves uh f5 by by lars
definitely wants to happen and that bishop on c6
um not to be underestimated because it stops both
rooks from going to a8 so if the action is on the
king side it stops black's rook from joining uh by
a8 you know and moving over to kingside and if the
action's on the queen side the rook on f8 can't
join so it's like kind of a funny piece here but
it disconnects both of the rooks very effectively
and on the flip side of things it actually blocks
white's access to the c file you want play rook
c1 and pile up against this backwards c7 pawn but
your bishop is stuck there so it's funny that both
sides are happy and unhappy about the bishop's
placement but look at this the board is opening up
queen f2 necessary because otherwise queen c5
would be a check that picks up the knight on
c3 i would still consider queen c5 to get into an
end game but then again there would be a knight e4
to follow maybe a punch through with d5 to d6 and
the b6 pawn gets weak so rook c5 does make sense
although 94 a kind of natural response attacking
the rook yeah has to be the immediate response
basically his rook on uh a5 was not doing anything
had to activate it decided look you can have an
id4 with tempo i want my rook doing something off
the a5 square and wow whoa tactics coming out here
knight g3 to e2 or knight d4 to e2 okay so knight
g3 to e2 coming our way but white's position looks
pretty good i put my queen in e3 just to cover
all the dark squares around the white king you
know king will go to h2 after 92 check and isn't
white's position better because the pawn on c7
is the easiest one to target not easy but easiest
relatively speaking yep i definitely feel that way
this c7 pawn is going to be a big issue i'm not
sure if lars is properly estimating that because
queen c3 is coming up after bishop b7 and the
problem is that if you think you're trading e4
for c7 the c7 pawn is more important because
the d5 pawn is passed the b6 pawn becomes weak
and maybe okay rook c6 he leads with the rook
that way when queen c3 happens you take on c7
and pin the black queen to the one and queen c1 is
possible here for example that rook is pinned oh
my gosh the bishop is just hanging out nice nice
fine and there's no queen g3 there's no discovered
checks discovered anything with that rook it might
be bishop takes h3 just because you have to do
something desperate times desperate measures and
he plays it can you take takes with the queen and
i'm going to check to be careful about that 10
seconds so how do you deal with that maybe just
brooke no queen of four's named a threat because
the bishop on b5 covers f1 so you could actually
play d7 yeah but as kenji won okay that move
makes a lot of sense queen if look at this defense
though great defense covering d1 threatening
queen f8 check and make the [ __ ] queen of fate
okay it's still very good for white
but he went the wrong way there
rook d8 is a great move does rook d1 okay bishop
one only move you found it it's a big move
before bishop b5 just win that b6 pawn and
push the a pawn king king to f4 though king g3
sometimes the bishop and pawn can be a little
clumsy but rook a1 is huge huge this is so roberto
right putting all of his pieces in defensive
before he goes in the offensive and look at this
the pawns in a7 here comes the bishop although how
does the bishop get in put it back on b5 and go to
c6 it's almost gonna go rook c8 yeah oh god e2 oh
my goodness e2 oh it's a thunder splendor and you
don't go for game one okay one oh my gosh oh
good move queen click on f1 and then rook takes
number b1 you get the check on the third rank wow
this might be a draw somehow i think it's a draw
what a game what a match this has been yeah
this is a draw for sure yeah with the g pawn
you just leave the king on g1 and this is why
you learn your end games everyone you can do the
first ranked defense with the g pawn because the
rook if it goes e2 to h2 there's no way in look at
roberto both of them nobody's happy with that
result no and what a game roberto had the win
lars turned the tables by finding this tricky
move after tricky move bringing that king into
g3 threatening mate and i think the problem
was roberto got too cautious when he could
have gone for a checkmate or just pushed his pawn
immediately to bring his rook and his bishop back
and i get why he did that it just did not pay out
for him in that game yeah there's always going to
be these moments where a certain style is going
to be better at executing a game there's lots of
cases where you know the more solid approach and
i can relate to this because that's my approach
i'm always the no counter play type of guy but
sometimes you have to make that you know important
decision to allow a little bit of counter play
but you forcefully calculate your way home
i was listening but what is this position yeah
good question honestly you were making a very
good point and i'm listening to you taking it
in and i agree with you that people believe
that playing risk-free chess is the safest right
playing super solid but sometimes it's actually
the riskiest way to play and the position
may call for tactics what is happening here
what is this i think i was trying to mask how
weird the position was with with a sort of
mundane statement like yeah you know so people
just try to do it's like let's just glaze past
this opening phase maybe no one will notice that
there was a bishop h6 knight h6 played by roberto
and then a you know h4h5 and a g5 played as a
response and hey guess what queen trade being
offered and no see this is interesting because
roberto would have probably played like knight
g1 to e2 to leave the queen trade on the table
or something like that and lars has no queen
trade and now e5 happens and that's the thing
is you keep the queens on the board and you
don't actually maintain what advantage the engine
evaluations seem to give white because black has
this really strong center yeah knight e 2 traps
the bishop knight f3 allows a fork so he has to
play this weird move bishop e2 and not what you
want the black king has not moved right so you
can still castle king side if you want not sure
you want to do that and white can technically
cast a queen side not sure you want to do that
either so i do not know where the kings are going
and queen g3 check here there's knight f2 the e3
score is defended by both the knight and the queen
so you don't actually land a knockout there
although it's just good to put your queen in
on white's camp i think bishop e6 just defend your
d5 pawn makes sense now i just am confused as to
what's about to happen we don't know where the
kings are going we don't know if the kings are
going we don't know anything the the black king
is so exposed there's only short castle i have
a feeling it might stay in the center however
you can short castle as long as you do not take
that g pawn um taking that jeep on here and short
castling very bad combo well looks like we learned
a bit more information about white's position as
well he will not be long castling and look at how
quickly roberto responded he had that lined up
he expected rook a6 and that's what happens over
a long match is you come to be familiar with your
opponent's style and the moves they might play so
you essentially can pre-move much better as the
match goes on and okay queens are off both kings
are safer i won't say safe because there's still
a lot of open space in front of them and knight
g4 so trying to distract the pieces from the c6
square and just from the queen side more generally
yeah understandable um i wonder which
piece he's gonna take with i can see a
case for both of them here bishop takes g4 you
know has the idea of bishop e6 to follow up
the only downside of bishop g4 would be giving
the d3 square with check and then maybe a rook
f2 to follow so that's a good point goes in this
move order and bishop e6 probably is too greedy
because of knight oh he goes for maybe
it's not but i thought knight d3 check
the king gets up to e3 wait how long knight
d3 i'm gonna play rook d8 next i just pin your
bishop rook d8 yeah and there's no king e2 because
of knight f4 yeah we're bd8 that's it oh that is
not that is not even good at all bishop takes e4
now that is doing well that's a huge miss yep and
this king on e3 is not happy though i'm confused
man i'm going to be honest with you chess is hard
i i see think that black is doing fine here
the knight on b2 looks weird with the pawn
c3 is under attack what's white's best
move now though i i have a feeling this
is the type of position that if someone's gonna
end up on top it's probably gonna be white um
this h-pawn in an end game can be very
annoying getting h6 some back rank issues
uh bishop takes e4 played rook c3 and king d2 so
uh the bishop on e4 is great it can coordinate
with this rook like rook h6 or rook a7 which
is exactly why rook c7 was played and do not
blunder rook b6 attacking the pawn knight c4
oops i actually think that white's position is
look at 20 seconds by the way even
look at the clock black has a good
chance here because white's king is in worse
immediate shape and there's 20 seconds for lars
yeah and those rooks are starting to staircase
together right like rookie 7 the king will run
away f2 and maybe castle at long last to g1 but
it was a long trek a beautiful journey though
king the g1 and i i think white's position is
starting to get pretty good like the the rook
b6 move can now happen h6 is one of those
annoying pawns you throw up the board and
that black king is never never really able to join
the fight yeah h6 would be a nuisance to deal with
you probably need to bring your knight back that
night on d1 it's reached the other side it doesn't
get a promotion so let's uh just bring it back
with some kind of knight c3 with tempo or maybe
e3 just creating some threats and does choose
knight c3 bishop f3 very solid covering all the
squares the knight could move to of course it's
an option to take that but i think yeah mars is
looking for a little bit more here he is and what
about rook b8 and then pushing that b pawn can i
get away with that he pushes it first by the rook
yeah i thought this i guess he push the b3 and
i i think of rook on b8 here would be amazing
for roberto and h6 he wants that pawn there
very annoying rook b7 starting to be some threats
although it looks like black is able to just put a
rook on d7 to fend off that attack on the h7 pawn
and here maybe even throw in king g8 at some point
but i understand leaving the king in the corner
just no checks available is that rook takes d4
as an option here i don't know if it's good
enough you you get the h7 pawn but remember the g
pawn and the h1 are so disconnected it might
not be good enough well look at this in comes
the knight around here but the b3 pawn about to be
lost you don't want to lose that pawn that's for
sure and you have no choice now i think you have
to go knight d4 and trade the knight for bishop
and just maybe draw the end game but now this is
getting risky there's no knight g4 check no and i
could see a stalemate by the way the king has no
moves knight f1 and the knight g3 yeah and rook
d3 if uh king h3 oh gosh and um rookie three that
was the worst blunder i think right the b3 bishop
is hanging as well and then rook d5 or something
like that maybe make g3 now wow you're hitting
everything that's a good response take d3 if you
take you through rookie five and there's knight d
f6 and the knight g8 go knight g8 i get the
feeling this is probably a draw but it's a
really weird position yeah because the pawn gets
the g5 then yeah you know the knight can't move
now it's a dead draw yeah rookie eight just pin
the knight and no moves yeah it's funny black
can just give up the rook and stalemate that is
worth doing i would take on g5 i would take on g5
and now he's gonna do it with check no i wonder
if he's actually trying to play for a win because
he's double piece but obviously there's you
can't move the knight it's actually impossible
yeah give him the rope all three of
these things over here h pawn king
h8 knight g8 they cannot move not
a single one of them so oh no fun
we have a lot of respect for the players they're
playing a great match but come on if you're gonna
make a draw don't do it by repetition give give
us the stalemate we've all been hoping for and
you see the players on screen roberto thinking
what could have been where did i go wrong lara's
just still looking really with intensity
at the screen and roberto actually seems
very upset right now yeah he's i think he's
just experiencing that that um you know
that expected emotion after so many of these
games seem to end in draws or you know lars
was down to like 10 12 seconds in this match uh
and he had almost two minutes and he's just not
converting them so i think he's he's just uh got
high standards for himself and he knows in this
match that every point is gonna count it's a tied
match uh as we have the break here in the three
plus one portion and you know it could
come down to a single game and then you're
gonna start to really reflect on the matches
which he's probably thinking about right now
for sure he had that knight d3 check and maybe
that rook d8 pinning the bishop i'm sure he's
thinking about that tactical sequence but all
in all it was a well-fought game there have been
ups and downs trials and tribulations errors and
brilliancies but we are going to take a break when
we return we'll come back with the second half of
the three minute plus one second increment time
control of this roberto lars i'm not gm speeches
championship match brought to you by chess.com
we just want to remind everybody of the format
for these matches there are 75 minutes of the
longest time control you've already been here you
know about all that we're about midway through the
three plus one time patrol we'll
get to bullet but right now we're so
locked up with such an even match you want to
remind everyone of the tie break format that if
this match ends the tie we get to a situation
where they play mini matches four games of one
plus one and if it's still tied we get armageddon
among you and i we don't root for players we don't
really root for results but how exciting would
it be to get all the way to armageddon well i
you know i don't even have to imagine how exciting
it would be because we've already experienced the
craziness in tie breaks like we had the tie break
between eric rosen and levy rosman and i don't
think we quite made it to armageddon but based
on how thrilling it was to even play those mini
matches and extra games with all the pressure uh
i think that uh armageddon would just be a treat
yeah it would be absolutely electric and right now
we have another vienna quiet variation we've come
to respect this and roberto did have a very nice
position two games ago so he's going back to this
lars has felt at home in this variation it does
give black a good degree of flexibility with the
minor pieces but white can control the center so
who do you think is going to blink first are they
we're going to see this all match yeah i i guess
the question is and it's just been answered are
we going to see bishop d3 again from roberto
i think that this was a great opening for him
but i don't think that he proceeded in maybe the
most accurate way so e4 e5 was their previous game
and i think that's repeatable for roberto but
obviously lars you know he had a great position
he doesn't mind repeating either and i wonder what
the players did during the break because sometimes
you look at chess i need to improve my opening
figure out where i could get a bigger advantage
or save myself when i got in trouble other times i
just can't look at chess anymore i'm in the middle
of a heated match and bishop d2 was played we saw
bishop e1 type of ideas in the first game of the
match uh the stuff it was the first game overall
if i'm not mistaken and so yeah here's bishop e1
once again yeah it's kind of interesting because
i feel like he's combining his two ideas from
both games but previously he had bishop d3 and
e4 and in the first game he had bishop c4 with
uh you know bishop e1 and then black took on d4
and here i think he's probably going to take with
the pawn and play the game the exact same way as
he did before but we look at what lars has done
differently he did not play rook d8 and then
go back to e8 he can get knight d5 because
there's no bishop on c4 so there's a few things
that are a little bit different here robert
that's right and also bishop a6 it seems like hey
wait a sec that pawn still hanging there could be
a bishop takes f3 which would force you to take
with the g pawn not very good or there's bishop
b3 to go win your a pawn so it's not that simple
here for white to figure out this position you
should probably not take on a6 i wouldn't go for
that i'd play something calmer like bishop c3 that
feels like a roberto move hey let's trade on my
terms if we're going to trade darts for bishops
right um well we're in the quiet
variation and rook a1 is totally a
quiet looking move um that's dealing with your
bishop b3 idea of forking those two pawns and if
a5 happens to save the apon here for lars it gives
up the b5 square and that's the square that white
can pretty permanently look to occupy and look at
lars go look at the d file there are minor pieces
on d76 and d5 staring at white's king side bishop
c3 that's an isolated pawn so you're just staring
into your own pawn bad bishops defend good pawns
so they say so i think that both sides are just
trying to figure out how to proceed from here
i like black's position though yeah agreed um
looks like there's going to be easy play for
both sides here in terms of where the pieces go
95 that's uh you know an automatic looking move
get in the middle of the board and now that apon
it's something to think about bishop takes a6
now a lot more of an idea because the queen can
no longer come to g5 after the knight f6 move and
the knight is no longer on f3 so there's no bishop
takes f3 um it takes a sec yeah you just said i
think queen b7 was a good move for black defending
a6 and attacking g2 bishop a6 he grabs it i'm
trying to read lars's expressions he's just eating
so i can't tell how he feels and he has the
best poker face ever because he's always
astonished he said bewildered and okay now i think
we're getting a little bit of a tell from him i
don't think he's very happy that he dropped the
a6 pawn but for the most part he does not react
yeah it's true um i mean the uh it
almost looks like so roberto molina is
probably shaking his leg because he's nervous but
it looks like he's in a massage chair yeah he's
got one of those nice gaming chairs that could
double as a sound like it's just shaking behind
you yeah maybe actually it is a massage chair
that would be pretty cool and probably helpful
but you i think you're right that both players
are trying to figure out the position we saw a
trade there on e5 and now white has the bishop
pair so i think that bishop e1 retreat you could
play bishop d4 as well if you want to be more
active but bishop e1 feels like the robertson
movement instead he just allows us we should
be capturing saying i'm up a pawn don't mind
liquidation takes takes pawn is going
to get to c4 um bishop's kicked out
extra pawn he's going to take it slow um and lars
that's you got to chalk that up to just a blunder
completely overlooked his apon and that's
the difference in the position right now
yeah that was not a sacrifice sometimes it may
be a dubious sacrifice but we all make those
that was just a blunder not recognizing that that
pawn could finally capture by the way 18 seconds
of counting down for black so it's a difficult
position down a pawn and you're down under 20
seconds but somehow lars when he's in time travel
he's the one who almost plays better so something
about this match so far lars has been able to
handle the time travel but right now rook d4
push one of these pawns take over the d file this
can't be good no not at all um rook d6 however
v6 rook d2 not the direction you want to take
this position no that bishop on b5 just keeps
control over the board take with the pawn i play
rook d4 just give me king f2 the rook on aid's
useless right now yeah the bishop on b5 sort of uh
anchored by and anchors these pawns so it's like a
nice trio that keeps the rook out of the a b and c
files and look what roberto is doing okay i didn't
like that move i thought he was going his king to
b4 i thought and he's bringing his king up this
side of the board but i thought that king d1 move
was a bit slow but maybe it wasn't and he's just
figuring this one out yeah he's he's at least
on the same page it's gonna be a5 because hang
on that rook comes down to c1 and lars is going
to be annoying he's going to be annoying here
very and how does white proceed because you're up
a pawn but the rook covers the b pawn the black
king of course keeps the d6 pawn in place
uh kings the rook went to b7 a vital tempo
yeah i think it's just ooh can't you take the pawn
now then rookie two check and then you name it
that's funny so what here rook b4 to c4
something like that look at this and king b7
wow now the king gets over king d7 is the try here
no fast is lost yeah and that's end game technique
for you by roberto and lars hoping for some
pre-moves but roberto has 50 seconds left this is
just an easy win at this point and with 20 minutes
left in the three-minute portion portion roberto
takes a lead once again he started off the match
up three to one then lars came fighting right back
tied the match up it's been tied for a while now a
one-point lead for roberto yeah let's see if lars
can bounce back and tie this match up again he has
changed his opening against roberto's karo khan
so he's going to e4 c4 and we've actually we're
actually getting a position very similar to the
position that roberto gets as white so we've seen
this before for example knight back we've seen
this exact thing these guys clearly have positions
that they like and look at this because he's
playing with the black pieces not the white pieces
he doesn't get to play bishop a6 aka bishop a3
that's a really good point and is honestly just
the same position colors reverse but a tempo
ahead for white that's how these things work and
right now the position looks very nice for lars
his style of position and roberto needs
to be careful so knight a5 a great move
trying to keep the d5 square defended and plugged
you just want to make sure that the e6 pawn feels
safe sometimes there are sacrifices on that
square ripping the king open and roberto doing
well on the clock lars keeping pace i think that
for now i like white's attacking chances but as
the game continues and the isolated pawn remains
i would favor black in any potential end game
and look out for knight takes f7 just generally
speaking oh gosh right here knight takes f7
i think 97 was was it i think i think it was
winning i i think it was it was about to say if
there's ever a move where the knight leaves that
square knight captures f7 we're hitting the queen
bishop takes e6 follows for example king takes
well bishop takes e6 and you're going to get mated
in a couple moves here there's no question about
that plus you don't even have to find mate you can
just play b take c3 after and it's game over yeah
that was that's a pre move let me check the time
he did not pre-move it he spent 1.4 seconds
but he is going to regret that he must see that
that he had the opportunity to sack the piece go
for the e6 pawn now after bishop f6 the rook on
e8 defends the e6 pawn so sacrifices may be in the
air later in the game certainly not the case now
and i would okay but c4 no this is
turning i would say in black's favor
no the yeah this is not uh this is not right
for sure because that d-pawn c-pawn all loose
normally you want pawn on c3 not c4 number one
it guards d4 supports the center number two
laughs at himself
oh my goodness oh my gosh lara's blundered the
mate and then lars is laughing and roberto is
like stressed he's like grabbing he's pulling
his hair out like dude you just made the guy
oh gosh well that was something and you know lars
may kick himself about missing the knight takes f7
he just allowed checkmate in one move
and you know we we know that pain we've all
blundered these kind of checkmates and we're
like oh how how could we we jolt back but for
lars at this point you've lost two games in a row
you need to really gather your bearings just
say i can do this i was just even i missed an
opportunity maybe he doesn't even realize he had
knight six f7 just yet but i blundered checkmate
in one in a perfectly normal looking position and
all right we're into this next game here i like
roberto's position once again the isolated pawn
i don't particularly enjoy playing with it but
something about it is to lars liking yeah and this
is uh as we said last time this is a repeat of the
exact same position um we've seen this before
bishop takes e2 it's got to be knight takes e2
um i'll just point out the difference here if
queen takes e2 if that was played then the d for
knight would simply be hanging because of the rook
on e8 so you can just go ahead and capture that
that would be a free piece so of course he he had
to move the knight back it's not the move he wants
to do but um it's the move that was required
here so he's just oh he plays bishop takes
f6 robert and that's a committal decision he's
going to grab that pawn and look to trade pieces
and greed is not always good because that rook
on d8 can land on the d2 square but for now
roberto's claiming it's not a big deal i can just
move my knight back to c3 from a4 knights on the
rim are dim so let's bring it back to defend a2
defend the 92 at the same time white is upon and
i see people asking uh to see that checkmate again
we will show it later we're just in the midst of
this game but don't worry we will definitely have
an instant replay as we head into our next break
so we'll keep that game up and we'll be able to
show it later but right now it looks like lars
is in trouble once again he's lost two in a row
he's down a pawn the next move for white almost
pre-movable is rook f to d1 then king f1 start
trading pieces and you're upon hat absolutely
um knight e5 you know an idea i think it just gets
met by either king g2 or even f4 um kicking that
knight out i'm i'm not so sure here this this
looks like uh a real extra pawn for roberto
it does and it's presence doesn't need to be felt
just yet but if you play f4 and king g2 king f3
just the long term advantage not to mention that
you have two knights as white against a bishop
knight combination that bishop on a7 will not
be able to defend the pawns on b7 and a6 so if
a pair of knights gets traded then white has even
more of an advantage to go after some of the pawns
yeah there's no way you can uh just trade
everything here it just just doesn't work
um after taste takes rook d1 i think we'll see
rook c2 i think we almost have to see rook c2
yeah the rook d7 though you had to do this
for black but this doesn't look very pleasant
this is terrible yeah rook d7 is rook
t7 is a lightsaber move but roberto i
think what he's up to is king e1 and rook c1
like those types of ideas he wants to force an
exchange of rooks he could almost trap the rook
like if the king could go to d1 right now if the
king of the rook would swap places king d1 the
rook has go to b2 and king c1 traps the rook so
you have to be careful if you are lars not to even
lose the rook but rook c1 as you pointed out that
looks like a pretty good move here yeah i think
kicking the rook out is an achievement because
if you go king e1 now there's bishop a5 which
is right quite a frustrating move so uh rook c1
and if rook b2 then i think you could go rook
b1 and king e1 oh there's actually a rook b2
because the bishops on b6 there's knight a4 even
better that that's an easy thing to forget that
you just brought your bishop there that would be a
little bit awkward yeah i was i actually only just
thought about it because like oh well what's the
difference in the rook moves and then the bishop
just came there so it would be a mistake and now
rook d6 i like that move your rook can go to h6
if white is not careful to win this h2 pawn and
for roberto right now king f1 back but you just
want can you want to kick the rook out so you
probably don't feel great about making this move
no you definitely don't um rook gets
you back and he says all right well
what are we doing here we're just doing a little
bit of a tango i think knight g3 to e4 makes a lot
of sense and he plays rook d1 so we've seen this
position before he's got to be careful rook c1 is
maybe three times yeah i think rook c1 rook
d2 should be three time repetition here
it just was done in a weird order although i'm
trying to check yeah f1 f4 was thrown in there
yeah f4 and bishop b6 so there were
a bunch of moves thrown in actually
and wow knight e4 allowing the rook to
take a2 because knight d6 check picks up b7
interesting moment here and honestly seven doesn't
seem like a great pawn to take bikini seven is
knight c8 so do not play king e7 ah very easy oh
oh we played it it's so easy to miss night scenes
it's regarded to see it oh he's staring at the
board he's getting as much he must see it if he's
staring at the board like this there's well he i
think he might eventually see it but i don't think
he sees it right now because he would play it
instantly if you oh we missed it he didn't see it
so i wonder what he was thinking about there may
be some kind of knight c3 to d5 if you could bring
the other knight in but both players having a sort
of blind spot to this opportunity with the fork
the the reason that he didn't play knight b7
immediately is because he probably felt yeah
that's a weird pawn to take which is sort of what
i was saying because i missed knight c8 as well i
was expecting king e7 knight takes b7 i was like
is that good for white and roberto's probably
thinking the same thing he did not even consider
knight c8 and to be honest robert you're the only
one who did of the four of us on cam here well
you know i was looking at knight fork earlier
so i still had in my mind maybe there's a knife
work somewhere and black is fortunate right now
because rook d6 check would pick up that knight
of course it doesn't because the rook defends
it rook d7 check well then the king just goes
back to e8 suddenly it looks like black is the
one who can start playing for more if white's
not careful thanks to this outside pass pawn
yeah rook d6 keaney seven might see repetition
i would play a5 from lars just push that pawn
there it goes and well we have a little bullet
scramble here but i guess at the end of the day
there's nothing black can do to get out of this
pin except for play king e7 so rook d7 rook d6
is just a fair i think it's a fair a fair draw
considering that uh lars i think buys facial
expression maybe maybe uh we can ask him uh later
but i think from his facial expression he knew
there was nice c8 there yeah i i wonder because he
did seem a little disturbed by how that game went
and when roberto started spending time i was like
okay well he's got to be thinking about something
i i don't know exactly what it was maybe
bring the other knight into the game or
something else but missed opportunity there for
him and he's still up two games so he should be
happy we see the bishop on a6 and this looks odd
to me i don't typically see games like this but
because you mentioned it earlier i i just came
to expect that roberto might do something like
yeah there's no way i would ever look at
this position and expect bishop a6 from black
but hey it's roberto and he's done it almost
every game so far and for lars he didn't play
bishop d3 bishop c2 bishop b3 this time his bishop
went through me and queen a4 by the way that's
always a problem with the bishop on a6 but queen
a4 i guess you have knight a5 to save the day
ooh he wants to do it this way takes and then
queen a4 there's knight c6 as a possibility mm-hmm
a seven pawn probably can be captured if you
uh make some bishop d5 type of move i guess
he's just winning the pawn and i'm looking now
at the eval bar on screen there it looks like
white's position is quite nice yeah i think
okay so he goes bishop d5 queen takes a7
yeah too soon queen a7 i guess rookie would trap
the queen but knight d5 first probably allows
you to steal that pawn a7 successfully yep yeah
yeah trying to like figure out what's wrong with
nabbing that pun and you know what's funny is
we've seen a bunch of positions today it's making
me question my evaluation because there's been
a lot of what i would consider pretty free pawns
um but the evaluation doesn't doesn't ever
seem to to reflect that compensation is strong
it's the problem with having an isolated pawn is
that even if you lose upon elsewhere you'll still
have the compensation because that pawn d4 is a
weakness and roberto right now is trying to figure
out okay i i should be in this and lars spending
his time looking at the best way to proceed here
and with the match situation the way it is with
the current dynamics of this board i think you got
to play knight takes d5 right yeah especially
like that bishop is such a strong piece that
if you let it sit there first of all you need a
good uh move in like in tow and also bishop takes
f6 knight d7 maybe that's what he was thinking
of i'm not too sure um knight c6 doesn't quite
do the uh the job here so he's gonna trade and
yeah i mean take a seven why not looks just good
you're up a pawn so the key thing here is trying
to make sure that you stabilize you brought the
queen back to not allow queen to c2 for example
and i i think queen d1 so he brings the point all
the way back i'm not sure i would have went to d1
at that point maybe b3 but the knight on d5 amana
i've had games like this where i'm like i should
be better i stole the pawn and you can never kick
the knight out of d5 at least not really so where
is or how great is white's advantage truly it's
uh always hard to realize rook c8 black owns
the open file um the queen's watching f7
he might just throw in a move like h6 or g6 he
goes for and yeah i mean this is tough robert uh
b5 b4 is also great counter play knight g4
threatens knight f6 and even if you get into
queen end game a rook end game there's always
going to be drawing chances for roberto that's
right i would try to get my queen son onto h6 but
that knight on d5 takes away both e3 and f4 so
nope no can do rook coming to c2 at some point is
well right now i guess rook c2 rook e2 we get a
trade of rooks perhaps and the outside past pawn
is what's the long-term benefit for white even if
currently the position looks quite nice for
for black rook c1 check keep the c file yeah
i like rook c1 tactically i would say
black is better here just your down a pawn
like if you put upon a7 black is quite a bit
better yep but and it's tough because you
can't activate your pieces very easily each four
played maybe there was an h4 idea by black there
so you just place h4 to prevent that and f7 is
the reason why you can't ever bring that queen
into the action right and if you can't bring the
queen to the action then at least white has a bit
of time and well i don't know where white's pieces
should go like rook e3 to c3 if i get both moves
at once i'm pretty happy but after rookie three
always have knight d5 so i mean c1 is the idea
oh so queen c6 probably is a good move for white
to try to trade queens and stop that infiltration
and queen c6 hits the b6 pawn tough to uh to do
something here so he's watching the c1 square with
that move and knight takes g6 as a threat yeah
knight g6 there's queen c6 but like there's some
times where you just you know move the knight
out the way and you can get away with it but
but knight d5 played you called it and now
queen b7 maybe yeah you do you have to play
f3 after queen b7 that looks it's so annoying
because queen b7 you can't just play king h1 very
easily because the knight could jump anywhere
on the board and threaten checkmate on h1
right so here comes f3 is not that's yucky it
looks no good at all and yeah i guess you're going
to have too much of a choice but after queen d3
that you have to trick queens the rook on b1 was
under attack ah but he win the d4 point so this
has been a pretty hard fought game to this point
and now black wins the d4 pawn white has the
outside pass pawn potential but it's even material
i was going to say i thought we were going
to see another draw with rookie 1 rookie 2
and for a d1 rift d2 and that would be something
and i think knight c493 um makes a lot of sense
okay this knight check is just gonna go back okay
so we could see a repetition king of six knight d7
but no lars wants more he plays knight to
c4 and king e2 yeah king i like that black
should probably go well not now i'd say go
for g5 but g5 doesn't work as 94 check yeah
i like the way it's hard to use i agree it's hard
to explain exactly what's going on to everybody
but a lot of maneuvering basically neither side
has a concrete threat so both sides are trying to
improve their pieces and their pawn structures
slowly and but surely and every single pawn
move has a consequence so f5 the knight could
come into g5 for example so you need to be very
careful he does it he weighs the consequences
and goes for it but look at that energy five
it's a very promising square for it yep e4 he's
pushing forward this maybe e3 rook d2 um ideas in
the position oh i don't like rook b8 rook c6 was
a more active way of going after the pawn on b6
while it's not anything no this could turn in
roberto's favorite very quick i mean it already
is turning in this video it is yeah so it's a
time scramble not much time and look at that he
went rook b8 and all the way back to g7 just to
go after the pawn he could have attacked to begin
with and rook takes b2 now the pawn is pushing
at some point very good though roberto he's
getting that king involved that's so dangerous
yes there's checkmate rookie tonight if three
only move king d3 then there's knight oh what's
easy three you gave away the pawn under the pun
oh no and king d2 so you have no you
don't have a draw king c one here
he sees it he sees it oh oh he doesn't see it
and look at roberto saw it he freaked out roberto
oh i'm lucky let's keep going dave shaking
his head why do they both see the tactic
well it's always one of them sees a tactic
never both of them right the person who
is falling for the tactic sees it and never
the person who needs to take advantage of it
exactly so what's happening here i mean there's
oh knight e4 is a big move he gets out of the pin
wait rook g8 oh the pins everywhere forks i don't
know what's going on one second barely
time for roberto to get his moves off
okay g4 oh barely got that move in time watch
out for the pin just move your king back they
both need to move their kings this is wild oh wait
that's just falling down watch out for knight f6
rook takes h5 okay so knight at four metaphor
breakage oh gosh can what where the rock the
oh my gosh and roberto just hits himself
on top of the head what is going on what
was that game this is the wildest match
right now and both players kind of look
like they're in disbelief about what happened
there lars you know won a pawn then had some
opportunities missed a fork that roberto
saw and then roberto was the one of two
pawns there then he lost one he was losing
the second but instead he dropped his rook
and white had the option to take that last pawn
off the board and instead just kept the rook on
for one move and black on the rook i can't believe
it that's really smart bullet play by lars by the
way in that rook a6 move just saying oh wait your
knight's under attack you forget that your rook is
hanging or don't just don't see it on the other
side of the board and well lars has changed his
opening he has played c5 earlier and now look to
e8 so um i guess we are back to similar territory
as some of the other games when he instead of
starting with rookie 8 and he played c5 first i'm
still honestly i'm trying to talk about this game
but look at roberto look at lars they're probably
still thinking about that last game i'm definitely
still really deep in that last game i'm on what
to say man uh unbelievable stuff there are the
blunders are everywhere in this match um and as
we've been pointing out it seems that the guy who
needs to find the blunder to take advantage of it
never finds it and it's never the same guy
so it's just whoever that person happens to
be they're just not finding it um when they need
to but the guy's blundering is always trying to
keep that poker face uh so you know the other guy
doesn't look at him on the zoo call and get any uh
get any ideas yeah and during a bullet scramble
i mean mistakes happen like that all the time so
of course we're not trying to be overly harsh
about the players chess and both players have been
allowing opportunities that otherwise wouldn't be
available so it's not just oh roberto dropped his
rook in that game lars is so lucky no lars has
also made mistakes that have allowed roberto in
fact he blunted checkmate on g2 a couple games
ago so exactly both players are benefiting from
mistakes but they're also putting their opponents
in difficult positions and you have to credit them
for that so right now we have two bishops versus
a night bishop pair the pawn structure better for
black in terms of pawn islands but with the bishop
pair you'd have to imagine that with pawns on both
sides of the board white should be the happier
side and a very small note is that if blacks pawns
i'd like to move b5 here i'm a big fan of
b5 but if black's pawn on a6 was on a7 his
position would be a lot better than it is right
now and he does play b5 i think that's great
um even if uh c4 gets played you have the two
bishops the fact that black gets to get rid of
all those queen side pawns means that i i think
are we gonna see in some weird way i feel like
right before every break and right before every
uh you know half time break we've almost seen a
draw like a very peaceful result these guys they
never go into a break with one of them having just
lost like tons of games and look at this just a
draw and actually there was only one moment that i
can think of from this game as soon as they agree
to a draw which i think we'll see in just a few
oh lars not mounting the draw immediately plays
rook to a8 that is funny because rook takes rook
would have been in the media draw and said lars
says hey let's play on a little bit the pawn e5
perhaps is the most vulnerable pawn on the
board i agree with them um the main thing is
that white's bishop doesn't have a good anchor
square because uh you know bishop on d6 suddenly
all your king side pawns are are loose and bishop
on e3 can't really guard e5 so he wants to play
lars wants to play king f5 attack that pawn you
know the rook's going to swing down a3 and a2
it's not winning but he's going to play a few
more moves it's going to be maybe an h5 h4
idea and he's going to continue from there yeah
this looks pretty drawn yeah just trade pawns
there if you win e5 you'll lose g5 and so that's
just an even trade if black could play g4 then you
would think about it but even there that shouldn't
be too much of anything g4 just take with check
my bishop can drop back to f2 if i need to block
the second rank so this looks like a very clear
equal position definitely um although i
understand lara's wanting to play on it's like
it's almost an ego thing you know if you're
slightly slightly preferred you just want to
play on and remind the guy i think he's looking
at g4 here um it's not really a big deal but i'm
sure that's the move he's intending yes both
sides they know that this game should and most
likely will be a draw but mistakes happen they
have been happening throughout the match you
just have nerves the tension of playing blitz for
so long and just getting into the bullet stage
of course lars wants to even the score and for
roberto he's played for a draw in this game
from a very early point so he's just trying to
ensure that he goes into bullet with the lead
and i mean this is an understandable try you know
black has a past bond here uh the e pawn runs
and basically if you can stick that bishop on g6
for black then you stop all of white's bonds from
pushing and yeah in the meantime you do have this
one so again slightly better not much but slightly
better gotta admit we take these advantages that's
for sure and the g2 pawn hanging so he goes back
bishop f2 i like the way lars is playing this
just you know you can slowly try to push forward
maybe f6 a little yeah just play f6 throw
that move in maybe play e5 to push that pawn
it should of course be a draw but lars is the side
with the upper hand especially now after king g5
yeah rook d4 rook oh rook a2 or k2 king
somewhere g3 g1 but it's getting closer
and closer to picking off one of these pawns
definitely some progress that's right and
i'm wondering like a bishop h4 rook f2 event just
solves all of white's problems immediately it it
looks like uh he's going to test it regardless but
i i agree with you it looks like it does yeah rook
f2 now you actually give up the g4 pawn for the
f6 pawn but once these trades happen and now it's
not double bad pawns for white against two solid
pawns for black no it's just bishop takes f6 and
rook takes g2 and i guess you draw that but that's
you draw that by keeping the bishop let's say well
you could take on g2 and play king f2 at the end
i know this because i did opposition practice
with some pogchamps participants so rook takes g2
does make a draw after king f6 is king f2 this is
actually very instructive the only reason robert
knows this because of the pop jam's instruction
no no it's the reason i remember it not the reason
i know it but rook takes g2 does force a draw and
roberto is thinking about it and if he plays it
it will be a drug actually did a stream where 40
i think 45 minutes here we're seeing just that
i was talking about you want to blockade the
pawn in the most advanced way possible but you
need to initiate oppositions of king f5 king f3
if king e5 king e3 you initiate the opposition
your king g3 or king e3 is fine because the
king is going away from the pawn so you're in the
most advanced square possible blockading the pawn
while still initiating opposition and lars knows
this as well you know pretty much the reason he
played on was to get this position right here hey
he's got an extra pun he he showed off robert he
honestly did play really well that game just
not enough to win let's uh show some of those
moments if we can pull up the past games just if
we can uh the knight c8 check uh some people were
asking about that we might as well before we get
into things we can find these games just in the
player history and then and we can also show the
checkmate in one move that was overlooked uh so
just a one point match this is really close stuff
we last saw levy rosman and eric rosen enter a
tie break match at the end it was that even but
these two players look like they're well in their
way headed towards an even match down the stretch
i see you pulled it up there so yeah this is the
this was the checkmate that you were referring
to earlier and we were sort of like chatting
about the game and didn't really notice what was
going on and big moment of course we mentioned
it in the broadcast knight takes f7
missed by lars and then as a result
an even bigger moment missed with just rook d1
blundering on the spot you see the evaluation bar
disappears queen takes g2 mate um just forgetting
that those pieces coordinated because remember it
was not uh queen g5 that was played by black it
was actually an exchange so sort of a tricky way
for that queen to arrive on that square that's
right always be careful about bishops on the
feed and keto long diagonal and this
one helped black deliver a checkmate
there was that other game where there was night
fork missed by roberto but you know you win some
you miss some it happens in blitz chess we
don't blame any of the players but amman
before we head to break any just thoughts heading
into bullet here as lars down only one point and
has been very strong in bullet in his previous
matches uh first of all this match there's a
reason we showed the tie break formula because
uh there's a good chance that it might be used
um so i think this is going to go down to you
know just a couple games in either direction
both of these guys 2 800 blitz players robert
so no joke at all um i think that each side
is loosening up we have a lot of blunders from
both sides so what i'm expecting from the bullet
is everything we've seen but magnified maybe
bigger blunders uh maybe bigger attacks
worse opening positions it's going to be
crazy i'm i'm strapped in i'm ready for this
robert but i think it's going to be a super
close match either way we may actually get
hybrid you may be strapped in but you can unbuckle
your seat belts for now we're going to take a few
minute break and when we return the players will
be back ready for bullet chest so i hope you're
excited everybody we'll be back very shortly for
more from the i'm not gm speed just championship
and the players are trying to win this match and
what's at stake there is prize money but they're
going to enter the finals against the winner
of greg shawty and levy rosman gotham chess so
amman you know of course the players here lars
and roberto they're focusing on each other on
the games ahead and bullet but which player do you
see winning on the other side of the bracket well
it's the you know the important question because
this is the other side of the semi-final the only
other match that's going to be played we know
all the contestants of who may reach the finals
as you can see from the bracket right here greg
number one seed going in i think that um you know
most people would have greg as the the favorite
based on his matches especially because levy was
toe to toe with uh canty for a huge portion of
that match and then with rosen it was more than
toe to toes toe nailed a toenail as they even
went into a tie break to end it off so uh levy's
matches have been closer uh but he's hitting new
high ratings right now robert um very tough match
to call but if levy continues at the blitz pace
that he's going right now i definitely think that
he has what it takes to take out the number one
seat greg shahadi and we have lift up i asked the
question cause i said greg was in chat so i just
wanted to hear your thoughts and look at this we
have this g4 f4 against the cairo again and knight
g3 quickly so we liked largest position when we
saw this earlier it feels like forever ago at this
point do we think that the players looked at this
at some point or they're just going based on their
history i feel like they're just going you know i
lars doesn't strike me as a as a look at things
guy he just strikes me as a go guy you know
yeah i wouldn't say that he is the theoretician of
this matchup but i like the way he plays it's just
really exciting chess he drops the bishop back to
f2 because knight f5 would have come with tempo
now knight if i would drop the pawn on
g6 so he did improve this a little bit
and he now plays h4 he's gonna go for h5 and
look at him we have the absolute five head cam
he is right up against the camera paying
attention to the computer screen actual
knight takes f5 very interesting decision okay
so he wants the g file to go against this now
pawn on g6 but black can also go against the h
pawn queen h7 bishop e7 things of that nature
and here we see that happen yeah and i think i
think that roberto should delay capturing on h4
i agree but i'm just trying to figure
out maybe if you could get your knight to
somewhere to defend g6 that would be ideal i
just don't see a way for the night to get there
like that's not going to d3 i'm saying
like knight b5 knight a7 knight c8 97 but
you can't you can't do all that it's a lot to
ask yeah too much so king should probably go
okay trades ropes this looks locked up i would say
amman you can correct me if i'm wrong i would say
black's position looks better to me because the
pawn f4 but that's not easy to go after either
yeah i think i think it is just exactly what the
engine is describing a very very even position um
if it gets spicy it's gonna be you know
some sort of c5 break trying to open the
the position up and black is
a little bit defensive here
as lars controls the position i think that the
only reason we might see a result is because
this is bullet that's i would say going to be
the case and i'm wondering which side will push
first lars is down a point on the scoreboard
so you may think that he's the one who's gonna
do something drastic but i'm looking at five
i'm looking at a4 pawn exactly the c5 looks
like it was ready and can you get away with
taking this a4 pawn that's the big question
i don't know about that oh but he has got to give
it a try remember the knight comes back to c7
that's true but queen f6 queen fe like that okay
trades rooks instead of going for the attack he
decides that the rooks off the board is sufficient
but the queen comes back to e8 now for black well
this is very bad for sure oh this is also that
queen go to b5 next if you're not careful queen
b5 right now hits b2 and you threaten queen f1
check if the king goes to c1 yep or queen e2 check
if the king is a queen e2 yeah queen e2 knight
d2 but the the queen on f6 is doing nothing just
queen before like there's not a single threat for
lars no there's not oh queen oh man take the queen
oh my goodness these guys are never
seeing the tactics they need to be seen
there was a queen hanging for free but it doesn't
matter in a sense because roberto is well ahead
here that knight on c7 is a wonderful blockade
and that is good overall match recognition by
lars to resign don't want to even waste
a few more seconds he has 21 plus minutes
he needs more games and we actually see a i guess
a very very uh uncommon opening the kohli system
you know normally people are getting that bishop
out turning it into a trampovsky or a london but
instead you see sort of an old system with uh e4
played and honestly has to be considered a mistake
that lack allowed e4 when his pawn was on b6 this
doesn't make any sense this is horrible for black
and usually there's this bishop on c1 is out in
the open somewhere but now it's not and well it
looked bad for black but all of a sudden with the
trades happening perhaps it's not so bad anymore
the bishop one d3 is so important to the king side
attack although this yeah still looks good i mean
the control of the center the light squares on the
queen side i would take white's position that's
for sure maybe rook b8 and b5 is an idea because
yeah i do prefer twice position the knight on d4
very very strong but it looks like b5 is some
source of counter play that that lars could use
so let's see and it's a two game lead right
now for roberto and honestly look at lars go
the knights getting into c5 and b4 that b3 pawn
not looking very good there i could see this
turning in lars's favor and i already like his
position i definitely agree but it's just wild
to me that after knight a6 threatening nothing
white decided to go c4 and allow the knight to
go to b4 so i don't get that decision at all well
roberto has shown some nerves i wonder if that's
a part of it he's just trying to come up with
good moves under the duress of time trouble
and now that there's a pawn in d5 that's an
isolated pawn that should be good for white
to go after i still think black's position is good
look at that knight coming to c3 real quick bishop
coming to c5 black's piece is coming to life yep
96 ideas as well uh rook e2 knight c3 so it's
gonna be the other night jumping in but but rookie
five that's yeah every everything is loose here
wow and f3 there's like rook takes
at five so he didn't go for that
and just an extra pawn for black yep f3
can trade the rooks there's king f8 for
lars if necessary strong bishop on
c5 look at that tying the rook down
on d1 and good pre-moving by the way from
roberto just taking that rook first and now
rookie two yeah the f2 pawn and then rook b2 to
go after the b3 pawn when you have a bishop vs
knight the side with the bishop wants pawns on
both sides of the board and i think rook d5 is
still good there's a5 as an idea um to follow
up and that's why he played rook c2 okay but a5
right you can just take it or move your bishop out
the way rook c3 there'd be rook d3 you don't quite
yeah and you don't quite want to trade rooks for
for black because the bishop against the knight
dynamic wait he could have taken on g5 right yeah
okay just making sure yeah he could have taken and
said he pushed and he's still better but things
are 95 though things are getting very messy now
f7 b6 all hanging yeah king had to step in
to the discovery g6 wow a5 a5 a5 85 huge
huge move i think you almost take it he did
take it now knight c5 and white is the one
up a piece for two pawns it's amazing how that
turned around and look at the clock by the way
you have to play this if you're large
but on honestly you could almost resign
oh it's resignable the problem is that it doesn't
matter if you if you lose this uh or not at this
point it's it's all about the time yes well
that's a oh hung a rook well he was mated but
well i i don't think he really saw his eyes kind
of told us that he was oh well that wasn't right
and well there's still 17 minutes left it's
only a three-point match and we were hyping
up lars's bullet proud based on previous matches
but it's clear that roberto came to play today
oh yeah now at 2800 you're you know you're not
getting that reading for no reason basically he's
playing super super solid and i think it helped
that going in he had he sort of had the upper hand
so he knows that lars playing from the back foot
has to play a little bit riskier that's right and
we have a position here where it's even material
white has a bit more space the knight can come
to e4 for example maybe you'll push upon a c4 at
some point but black has no weaknesses to target
honestly these positions frustrate me because
i look at them i'm like white should be better
the engine's saying what does it say i see the
eval bar it looks like it's really good for white
and like how to break through honestly playing g4
is a good start rook h1 now swing up to h7 good
work by lars so far yeah and i like playing 95
in these positions and taking with the pawn um
at some point you'll kick that knight out and the
bishop on g5 is so so dangerous you know there was
an f5 move there that he could have played because
the rooks were hitting each other so you have to
be careful about that kind of stuff and lars is
all in on against the f7 pawn he just remains to
be seen how he attacks it again all light squares
as you can see all light squares from uh roberto
the rook on g7 pretty much nullified by the
rook on d7 which is central and doing a lot more
look at that yeah great move a3 rook f3 he's just
playing very well right now and rook c7 can happen
the rook can just move away said king c6 first the
e3 bishop can be captured at this point lars just
hoping to hold on and make a draw because honestly
roberto's dominating this game he's dominating
and i see roberto kind of looking on the side of
his eye i'm guessing he's looking at the overall
match time so for everybody's awareness
the players they're sharing their screens
with uh the proctors no nothing's amiss there fair
play is being upheld but they also can see the you
know keep a timer to see how much time is left to
make sure that they're uh and the players can also
and i think that's a good resignation these are
terrible games for lars he's got to get better um
the other thing that the players are often
looking at which is why i say the word poker face
um from time to time is they're looking at
the zoom and that's a very real strategy
look at the call between you and your opponent
yeah you're both on live you know cam for a reason
uh a lot of the players have said in the post game
interview they're often checking their opponents
after every single move just to see their reaction
you know if they think they played a good tactic
check the webcam what are they what do they
think of it very true because normally when
you're playing over the board you see that
your opponent's expression just in front of you
and here with the zoom call you can look at
it a lot of players keep it off to the side
and honestly i think more people keep it uh open
and closed some people get distracted by it but i
think most want to see their opponent's reactions
to get a better sense of the board but right now
lars up 15 seconds i like his position we once
again have an isolated queen pawn but there's a
knight coming to e5 or maybe back to e4 the rook
can go up to e6 or something knight c1 well 95
i mean you have to like lars position f4 he
blunders that four he knows it oh he just laughs
but it's just laughter because you're frustrated
about situation after situation not going your way
that uh that is the worst move to play there and
it's such a natural one too that's the sad part
i think black slows chances by the way like
this rook bishop takes h3 next rook g5 to follow
you be really careful if you're roberta and you're
down quite a lot of time yeah i think queen d2
that looks strong oh bishop takes h3 take
that one of course oh gosh and that's
that's two pawns right no doubt in my mind we're
capturing that so it's two pawns for the piece
and white is an exposed king and white's down
under 20 seconds so i think that lars has a
very legitimate chance i love that move queen
f4 though yeah that's a great move so strong
bishop e2 forcing the queen back into uh you
have a trade now you're down a piece for real
for real for real it didn't feel that way
with the queens on the board because the
king could get some trouble but now it's
off it's much clearer knight c4 getting the
uh not even hitting the b-pawn wow nope great
play by roberto those knights on d3 and d4
so strong look at all of white's pieces they're
involved they're compact nothing's hanging
and the e6 bishop is going down in just
a moment here taking them bishop h5
oh okay rook h4 played now king h8 now okay bishop
h5 now there's a bunch of chats to get out of this
right rook f6 still the e pawn hangs oh okay or
it doesn't and now 94 perhaps it feels like black
is sort of yeah 7 97 97 missed okay and now it's
once again still something seven ninety seven nope
okay rook takes no rook 65 rook takes f3 is what
i was looking for but i don't think it works out
yeah this rock takes g5 at the end yeah the knight
forks were so close but not working and look at
the amount of time it's like roberto's uh he's
trolling because he's he's allowing lars some
chances so lara's like yeah i'll keep playing
this game but then he's taking so much time off
the clock so it's like it's kind of a brilliant
strategy yeah just the overall match time 11
minutes left and they're just going back and forth
no draw to be made and black's much worse so it's
time being taken and your position's oh wait a
second especially not getting better but the 95
is he holding this take this draw he's got
four seconds i think he'll take the draw
wow what a hold though by lars oh no okay that's
that's nope can't do that cannot be playing for
wins in positions where you're losing if you
don't take the draw oh i don't have enough
criticism to give that decision that was probably
one out of just pure frustration that you keep
and there was a four the knight loses defender
wait a second take that knight and now he's up a
pawn so maybe he made the right decision amman we
gotta stop no but roberto's a troll because he's
gonna draw this game he just plays a6 and it's
taking more time off the clock it is a deep a deep
strategy from roberto oh gosh my man the deep fake
here where he well he better hold this game then
because otherwise he can't justify it anymore
but yes it looks like he's holding this game
this is unbelievable this is nasty and it's
taking so much time we're down to 10 minutes
left yeah yeah it's almost he's almost won the
match i think he's won the match basically well
you need to start the have time to start the last
game so if lars can win the next four games after
this in nine minutes and 45 seconds he still will
have time to play that last one and the only thing
to watch out for is like a rook d2 g4 check and
the checkmate but you're not getting this this is
this is just a draw just repeat moves okay
he's bringing the king there but unfortunately
there's no uh oh rook f5 yeah okay we're gonna
find white could have played play it's already
moved 106 we would have had at least 160
more than that we've been like 250 moves
guys this is actually oh playbook a8 yeah
don't take it don't take it oh my god this is
actually five head roberto this is brilliant it
is and just keep playing do not agree for a draw
as long as you don't blunder your rook
you're going to make the draw anyway
oh my goodness move 116. yeah this is
honestly just fantastic match play here
and there's no way at this point
that white can lose the game
at this point even if he lost the game i
would this is where you just type worth
and just look at him he's just like this is
ridiculous right oh then we got to finally get
the trade that was you know we were getting close
to fit like he he did all he needed to do there no
he did that and then more we were talking about
11 minutes left and now we're down to eight and
a half so he spent two and a half minutes
making the draw that could have been made
a while back and that's on mars he took that
bishop on e4 which he should not have done yeah i
can't believe he uh even put himself
in a position to draw that game so
you know some credit over to lars there for that
one but really what just happened there was not
good for the lars uh camp well this looks
really good for white though this position
i uh yep i like e3 how do you stop the g6
played bishop h6 is there something knight d5
knight f7 at some points really close but i don't
think it works so how to make it work so close
oh it's so frustrating to have this position where
you know you're doing well and you can't put the
game away mm-hmm and knight c4 okay knight
c6 just trying to trade the knights off like
at this point is it knight f7 knight or 95 queen
d5 knight f7 bishop a2 and d5 do you just go like
insane go all in just do about uh everything
yeah i'm just gonna you know i'm gonna go like
nike five knight f7 bishop a2 you know this is me
i'm over here robert i'll be here all day you know
i like it i like the idea um you know it probably
wouldn't work out objectively but i'm still here
for it and how about take on g6 now oh it takes
on f7 she's okay he'll take on f6 and take on h7
and then take on g6 he's taking everything fair
fair so i'm looking at the clock six minutes
and 50 seconds and somehow the evo i didn't
like that move it looked fine to me but i'm
just looking at the match clock because lars
needs to win and needs to win just instantly
every single time i think the reason that knight
d5 wasn't preferred is that you don't need it to
play bishop f6 queen h7 and you may as well
keep pieces on the board you never know when
or how you're going to need them right the king
pasta is more room to us what the kings on f6
that is queen h5 head right there that
was so smart the queens have to come off
that's why you don't play knight d5 robert right
there that's the answer gosh that was so smart
that that that he was already well instead of
winning the match but that is securing it and
robert definitely just said that was queen h5 i've
been ruined or you know i'm kind of ascending to
the next level i'm not sure which one but either
way twitch lingo is the vernacular has entered i
yeah appreciate that just wow wow wow roberto
has proven his might from the very beginning
even before the first match took place we talked
to kriker mkhitaryan grand master from brazil
very popular streamer and he was just telling us
you know we we know roberto from playing him and
seeing his games but he was just
saying this guy is real strong
he hasn't had as much opportunity as you would
like to become try to become a grandmaster but
he said to us in a post-match interview that
he wants to become a gm and i've been very
impressed with his level of play throughout
this tournament i agree i agree 87 and 56
you know he's just like this is this is at that
point you know you might have mouth slipped
rook d6 but what does it really change um
doesn't do much for this match doesn't do much
sorry for this game it doesn't do much
for this match no and lars he was close
heading into the bullet and just one of those
days where evenly rated players one shines and one
has to say i i don't know what i could have done
differently this was just a fantastic showing by
roberto so both players have been excellent we're
getting down to the final stretch of games here
four and a half minutes not enough time to erase a
five point deficit and lars has a decent position
right now just at this point you're in the mindset
of it doesn't matter i lost so who cares if i win
this game even if prize money the second half
of the prize money is split by one percent just
you already feel deflated exactly queen f4 good
move by the way but um knight g4 nitro real good
he4 g3 queen h6 i was thinking but um probably
still available to some degree after bishop d7
i like knight g4 you have to play g3 and queen h6
you have to play h4 so there are no options there
okay now getting the queen back you know queen
g3 these these are going to be easier moves to
play and this big three sorry as you say this
bishop one d3 is so strong like it's underrated
but that pawn c23 configuration can't cover
everything whoa he wants rook h4 i think but i
was gonna say rook h4 first and then maybe brooke
uh she takes h3 and look at roberto f4 honestly a
pretty smart idea by lars just trying to win the
game and it doesn't win and f4 says well no rook
pins for you yeah queen h5 is threatening nothing
and a queen trait man roberto these queen trades
are they're they're spicy like these are like
tactics how he finds these queen trades seriously
he's just so on point when it comes to styming
his opponent's attack and just trying to trade
off pieces to make his king feel safer he's shown
a prowess in that many times throughout the match
and looking to keep playing could take draws
i mean it's totally uh up to him at this point
oh this looks too good for white to just make a
draw king d2 even play f5 in the near future start
yeah there we go even though he doesn't have
to he's even making this game last a long time
oh he's probably just going to win the game
yeah right up a piece for how many pawns
just two pawns was about to be one and then
probably about to be zero f and rook d7 now
yikes no this is from bad to worse to just
you know feeling yeah there's nothing yeah
there's nothing uh nothing to do here guys this
is just a very very well played finish ooh brick
to f8 check for style point that's oh he plays
it wow that is beautiful 10 out of 10 over here
10 out of 10. yes that is a fair rating for that
rook f8 wonderful stuff and roberto this was
closer than the match would indicate right now but
honestly after going through 25 minutes of bullet
it does uh queen a5 check i was like what is
bishop of five it's actually a line but it feels
not that close i don't know how do you reflect
upon this match right now uh completely outclassed
and bullet um i think that it was i think that
it truly was um super close in in the blitz and
actually i was really impressed with uh lars let's
dress so i thought that going into the bullet
it would definitely be a close match because i
think he needed to keep the blitz square close
in order to have a chance there but i think
what roberto is showing is that it does have
the style for bullet that's solid style
queen trade you know stay up on the clock
lars is basically sort of flailing going for
speculative sacrifices and the thing with that
style is that when it works i mean you're kind of
sailing you're feeling great but when it doesn't
work you often experience a very good defender
and i think he met one today in roberto molina
a very good defender is able to frustrate
that style in a way that is so so annoying
and earlier in the match i think that lars
was playing well and caught roberto in a
style he wasn't quite comfortable with i
mean i see a knight in f5 and a reminder
that earlier game on lars was black and roberto
sacrificed the pawn but lars played really well
to save his king and then win uh the game and here
it looks like you know the last flails as you said
for lars at the time is about to end right
trying to make things a bit spicy go after
the g7 pawn hope that you can get one for the road
a victory last one and i guess bishop g7 queen g4
it backfires you get mated first yeah
there's not a good way to to do this
but knight's going to come back to g6 and that's
going to be an extra d-pawn yeah f6 yeah you can
blockade the d-pawn but you're still down upon
the knight comes back to g6 you might just sack it
you think so i think there's a very real chance
yeah it just doesn't amount to much at least
in terms of attack the match is over yeah you
might as well logic so well done by roberto very
impressive and he's farmed how many rating points
at this point like 40 rating points from lars
and honestly and the resignation happens the
match is over just just you know yeah yeah it
didn't make a difference he just wants
out yeah he's wonderful he wants out so
what i was going to say is i'm not sure it matters
who roberto faces i think he's the favorite just
based on what we saw today in his previous matches
yeah he's he's basically made a case for himself
in bullet like uh not many others have
and he's made a case based on consistency
2 800 level bullet but a consistent style not
necessarily the most tactical you know he goes
toe-to-toe in tactics when he needs to but
he doesn't initiate those tactical sequences
um uh i think he's got a very solid style and that
means that he's rarely going to have matches where
he has blowouts so today is really an exception
to that he just played amazing and bullet lars
didn't have the the attacks the sacrifices and you
know his intuition didn't go his way today but in
general i think uh he brought up a great point
roberto is looking dangerous and you know greg
shahadi and levy rosman watching this match and
going oh man i'm not even sure i want to win if i
have to play him well we'll hear from the players
in just a few moments we'll get their thoughts
in a post-match interview stay tuned everybody
lars and roberto will be joining us very shortly
and we are back joined by the players
from today's match that is roberto molina
and law's oscar hogg welcome guys uh i
go over you to to start there roberto the
the match was a very very close affair today in
the blitz portion both of them actually and then
it was actually the bullet section where
everything everything changed and the final
score didn't feel like it reflected the match um
how did you feel about the match overall because
it looked like it was very close to us going into
the bullet yeah uh i i think some games i was
with a good position and i i blended
something but the same way to hosh and
i think if he in these games i i was more
for example playing it accurate i think it
uh maybe the score in blitz will will be
some different difference but ah it's it's
it's not my blitz now we can win uh we can
be winning but after a blunder you can lost
i i i dropped some pieces i don't remember there
i definitely agree and lars on your end you were
facing an early deficit but then you evened up the
match it was even for a long while and then
towards the end of the three minute portion
roberto started winning some games including
a checkmate in one on g2 would you say that's
where the match got away from you even before the
bullet or was something going wrong in the bullet
uh yeah like the last two of the blitz games
went like poorly when i blundered mate in one one
unlike even either the game before that or after i
played very poorly so when i went into the bullet
and i lost i just knew that i didn't have a chance
um so i started like in the both games i just gave
away all pieces to try to end the game fast but
it's it just ended in me losing every game so
i didn't stand chance in the bullet but i think
maybe i could have if i played a bit better
in the blitz games because then i wouldn't
have been so aggressive in the blues games
yeah it makes sense to to go aggressive when
you need those points at the end speaking of
aggression you know to highlight some of the good
moments you actually had a really nice attacking
game in in the blitz portion where you had his
king all the way out on h5 g5 running around and
there was a a nice checkmate that looked like you
were going to deliver if uh if he didn't flag but
that i believe that was against his power khan did
you do any preparation against the the karo khan
because that's that's one of his uh main openings
i believe yeah i i mainly prepared that's black
not that much as white so i just thought that i
would go for the um i played like a year in the
advanced version like a knight c3 g4 line which i
had like i knew pretty well but when you played f6
i didn't know what to do so that was the end line
and like kind of prepared in the car calm yeah
and roberto on your end we were very impressed
when you had some difficult positions you were
able to trade queens but do so very resourcefully
and tactically what can you say about your defense
today because that was just as impressive as
some of your more tactical aggressive games
my style game is is always like this
changing queens going to 80 games isn't
looking for for some technical position
complication complications uh positions
with very high complications i don't like
so much and i prefer to avoid this but
it's for example some gaming with kingy e7
i think i will lost that game but in the
beginning of the match he said i don't like this
position but but sometimes we need to play you
know but i prefer change queens and play in games
and understandable um and lars i wanted to ask you
about a position that it looked like you guys were
both repeating from white and black it seemed like
this isolated pawn position um you were constantly
getting it with white and black is that because
uh you thought you had good chances here
or you know you you were you were happy
getting that position every time uh yeah i was i
i was happy with that position both with black and
white so i just kept going for it but uh i think i
still scored pretty badly in those positions like
when i had the black pieces like i kept wandering
on my six and in the car con games with white i uh
like the attack never worked so it didn't turn out
well i was happy with the openings in almost all
the games yeah you know it was a fantastic match
and uh roberto would be remiss not to ask you well
you'll face the winner of levy rosman gotham chess
and greg shahadi do you have a preferred opponent
between those two no no i think both players are
very great and i just will watch in the games and
maybe start some preparation i don't know
but i will just watch the games justice
yep i think that's the best preparation you can
do and if either of those guys were were watching
this match i'm sure they're they're going to
be uh well aware of of who they're they're
going to be facing in the in the final um well
guys i won't take more of your time but uh lars
thank you for uh the interview and and the
match you made it very far in the competition so
i hope you you definitely take solace in
that because we were always entertained
uh watching your matches and uh and also
to you roberto congrats on the match win so
gentlemen i'll let you go but thanks for for
participating thank you thanks for reporting
thank you and congratulations once again to
roberto molina as you see in the bracket in front
of you he is the first person to make his way to
the final he looked dominant in the later stages
of this match at the end of the three minute
at the bullet section of course i think he won
every single game and amman he faces the winner
of greg shahadi and levi rosman now he did not
say who we'd prefer to play he's a very nice
guy i honestly don't like asking that question
because it feels like you're leading them to
some answer i just have to ask the question he
you know he didn't answer he's very professional
he said i'm gonna play who i have to play and i'll
prepare and all that good stuff but what do
you think based on the styles we saw uh sorry
the games we just saw from roberto whose style
is roberto's play better matched up against
um well it's kind of interesting because if he
plays against greg i feel like those games are
going to be very very technical that's sort
of how i i feel like greg likes to play so um
not that that matchup is any more likely than the
rosman one but if uh roberto likes those kind of
queenless middle games into end games technical
positions i feel like he can get a lot of those
against greg so it'll be basically who's better
at that style i feel like in that match whereas
levy i mean you're going to get fireworks no
matter what you're going to get time trouble
there's always going to be other factors at play
in a levee rosman match and that's why his matches
are so exciting so i think for different reasons
both of those matchups could be very exciting i
agree completely and for roberto what is showing
today in the semi-final he should be really proud
of himself because that was a stressful match
we saw him earlier he was hitting his own head
he was almost pulling his hair out it seemed like
he was the nervous one and yet when it came down
to the quickest time control he was the one that
seemed very composed in the bullet finding good
move after good move finding the tactics when they
became available making sure his king was safe
when it needed to be protected so i have to say
that was an extremely professional performance
by roberto molina in today's match yeah i mean you
you summed it up lars is an incredible player and
the final score made it look like that might
not be the case but of course it is the case
i mean you don't make it to the semi-finals for
no reason lars has been so dominant especially
in the bullet portion so for that to flip around
today just speaks to uh you know lars was saying
i was trying all these it's just attacks
they weren't working but that's full credit
to the defense that roberto put on today so super
impressed by his resourcefulness defense able to
trade the queens as you highlighted there's just
so many things that roberto did well that i really
feel like whether you know he did preparation
or not he seemed well prepared for sure and they
mantra is defense wins championships and roberto
he's the first to say i want to trade queens i
don't want the complications i prefer to have
positions without all the tactical sequences
where i have to be worried about missing
one little thing that just loses the game
so roberto style he's made it well known we'll
see who we face off against the final but aman
i gotta say it was another great day commentating
with you i had a blast this match was excellent
full of ups and downs there were mates in one
hung on the board there was time pressure galore
and yet everyone was happy we still have nearly
10 000 people watching so i just got to say thank
you again partner it's been a fun ride and we
still have another semi-final and a final left
yeah let's you know remind the people it's been
uh awesome today but there's been so much chess
happening that i feel like people need a reminder
now and again about this tournament because we're
getting into the semi-final match with
levy as well as the uh eventual final
match between you know whoever wins that match
and roberto molina and this tournament has
been so exciting to cast that i think with all the
hype with pogchamps we just got to remind people
that hey this tournament is not done yet and
it's only going to get more exciting from here
filled with great chess content creators great
personalities and fantastic players i think
people often forget about that and i know peter
svidler is a great example where people like
oh he's an amazing chess commentator and
every now and then i have to remind people
he's also an amazing amazing player who has really
just a great impact on our game so i have to
give a shout out to all the players in this field
there are only three left roberto in the final
he'll await the winner of greg versus levy but
you're right this has been fantastic we are in
for a treat we've already had a great time there's
more to come so everybody enjoy the rest of your
days enjoy chess and do not forget on march 8th
we will have levy vs greg we'll see you there